donkey No
yeah what is up everybody
good morning very early morning if you
couldn't tell by the sound effects
it is early the early sound effects yes
this is how we began our runnings anywho
what is up everyone Persia here and I'm
with Erin today hey Gazoo and we are
checking out some Borderlands 3 oh snap
so first things first we kind of already
jumped past the very beginning tutorial
parts here so we can get straight to the
action for you guys cuz they're actually
really excited we're gonna friend here
first thing in the morning for a reason
or I excited to check it out I'm trying
to get past the parts a lot of you saw
from e3 we had like download a new build
last night but realistically a bunch of
us are either like almost completely
done with the game or you know level 30
so we can go up to a certain point in
the game that's a couple hours in we'll
see if we make it there and but also we
can answer any questions you guys have
about you know which vault hunter you
guys want to play I played I played a
ton of Zane I'm currently playing Zane
he's a my favorite I think he's like a
he was like an Irish bastard he would
rather be in a bar he's an old man and
he knows it he's got a sick digi clone
here we go say hello did you clone nice
and you know the it'll take me a little
while to get through this tree but I'm
currently running like a pretty insane
grenade spamming build you can do with
him we're almost everything you do just
basically spawns a grenade hey that
sounds pretty convenient because you
were talking about how ammo can become
pretty limited dude I I was trying to
remember if this happened so much in
Borderlands 2 and honestly people can
speak up in the checks I know there's a
lot of Borderlands fans out there but I
ran out of ammo a lot in the first
couple hours of this game even even
later on I ran out of ammo quite a bit
let's see not such a dog guy honestly
yeah what are some of your favorite
weapons who the COV weapons are really
cool because they
don't need to be reloaded they just cool
down and they have these really
hilarious reload animations where you
literally like spray them with a squirt
gun guns but the the tracking weapons
are kind of the boss killers like a lot
of the bosses in this game are very
spongy and the Atlas guns just let you
tag them and then kind of duck behind
cover maybe hide a bit if you're playing
solo and plink them without having
direct line of sight which is kind of
critical so yeah we're just gonna get
through this first first mission that a
lot of people have seen we also have
Jordan in the chat and he is also a part
of the game spot squad he's played a ton
alongside Aaron so we are here to answer
your question he played a lot of moves
with an iron bear than mech it's like
the most titanfall character in the game
man I had such better luck this run we
went to a preview event and all I found
were like these crappy pistols and this
time around it's random every time yeah
the loot is really random now one
interesting thing is the loot like seems
to drop a couple levels above where
you're at a lot of times which is can be
interesting sometimes like you can have
a favorite set of guns and when they
become a little obsolete you can find
yourself dropping a new set of favorite
guns but they're above your level so you
have to grind up to them so you can be
you can have like really good sections
then you can also kind of be stuck in
lurches where you're waiting for that
next crop of amazing weapons but
fortunately in a in sanctuary which is
your your hub it's your ship there's a
really cool gun wall where you can hang
up your old guns and you know every time
you come back to sanctuary you can Mary
condom touch it see if it still brings
you joy and if it doesn't then you trash
it yeah
is it we are currently playing on PC but
this will also be available on the 13th
for ps4 Google stadia and Xbox one I am
curious if people are into the idea of
stadia because it's it seems like it's
just an idea right now um you know it's
hard to tell people are interested
without having their hands on it
but it could be a good way to play a
game like this particular with the
ability to go different places so here's
my skill tree real quick
sorry just hot hot change the topic real
quick I know all good so like most of
what I like to do was A&R grenades so he
has the ability to randomly fire grenade
it happens pretty often and then you can
give your digi clone a grenade and then
you can let your digi clone do a cryo
Nova every time you switch and then you
can also have your digi clone explode
when they're done so when you combine
that with say like you know Merve
grenades that already split out into
multiple other grenades you just end up
with absolutely insane grenades going
off everywhere all the time
you kind of become a danger to yourself
if I'm being honest which is not a bad
thing let's point em I'm gonna pull in a
TD or weapon cuz these are way funnier
than they were before too you see yeah
that was gonna be my next question like
what are some of the biggest differences
or it may be updates or maybe things I
do the same as the other titles it feels
like there's been just enough time
in-between releases and there's just
enough improvements in sort of graphics
fluid movement the humor is not over
it's over-the-top humor but it's not as
excessively as excessive like all the
time as it was before I see it I see it
just feels like a really dialed in
Borderlands and it's been it's been long
enough since to what it's been like
seven years that it just feels good to
have to have this game back yeah
reunited I don't know if people out
there played pre-sequel that was the one
that I kind of fell off on
so if you--if you dumped a ton of time
in a pre-sequel I guess that that time
frame is a bit shorter all right let's
get my dizzy clone up can all the
characters slide asks pause yeah they
can they can also do a um like a ground
pound attack which most the time I
forget to do it's a jump crouch attack
oh okay nice so they can all slide they
can all mantle and they can all do like
a ground pound these CDR weapons are
honestly better reloading than they are
shooting a lot of times they were sort
of originally in Borderlands 2 they were
I don't know like the Walmart of guns
they were just disposable and this time
around they are not disposable in the
same way they are they're deadly when
you reload also a lot of these weapons
have a two firing modes so I can and
their sights will typically change when
you go to those firing modes so CO view
weapons here actually here let me do a
quick flat off gun you'll see me switch
weapons a lot mostly because I'm running
out of ammo so these have an alternate
fires well at least we get to see all
the game I apologize in advance
I am compulsive with wanting to try
everything people in the comments will
probably tell me multiple times that I
have not switched to the best gun
available it's mostly because I just
want to see what guns can do it's like
the joy of Borderlands it's just see a
shotgun with a scope just not super
useful oh you got the turret back up
yeah so yeah you can you can switch to
get out of the way okay so this blood
I've gun has increased rate of fire
there's also pistols that have a fire
like a
an area denial taser which is super
useful yes we are playing on PC
currently I'm gonna play with a
controller though because reasons yeah I
feel like I'm fully spoiled by the
controller now it's just here's the
thing with controllers they're more
comfortable for absolutely everything
except for shooting which unfortunately
you do a lot of but they're just I don't
know man they're just better that's it's
subjective oh it's very subjective like
I always say it depends on you know what
you're raised on some people here start
early like a PC shooters and stuff like
that
I've gone back and forth over the years
and I think a lot of it has to do with
aim assist has become just a lot better
it's like what 1 to 1 on a gamepad it
just doesn't work it feels terrible
you're always overshooting your targets
there's a dude man I'm already getting
good at this game I already killed the
guy I was gonna kill that I was worried
about killed him with our minds yeah
you'll see me picking up a lot of chests
again as I said earlier that's mostly
because you've run out of ammo a ton
particularly in the beginning hours
before you get the sanctuary and you can
buy some of the ammo upgrades let's see
I don't like like the Jacobs guns but
some of you might and that is that is
cool any FPS drops not that I've seen
really yeah nothing particularly bad I
mean these are still these are not final
builds of the game let's go with that
I'm just gonna swap weapons all the time
yeah we want to see as many weapons as
possible anyways that's that's just
what's that'll work Chris G asks does
flak have slower movements since he's
bigger or do they all move the same
speed you know that's a good question I
didn't I can't answer fully but I I
played flak and I didn't notice any
particular differences in movement speed
I know some of the abilities like Moses
iron bear has some modifications to let
it close distance more quickly
good morning Brandon hello good morning
thanks for joining us thanks for joining
us so early
playing some Borderlands 3 for those of
you just joining us we pretty much
finished the game but we were asked to
you know start over again today with a
preview well it's like an early access
build of the game what are you throwing
weapons I was sharing with you guys yes
yes please I want this I love how a lot
of weapons in this game are just they're
not necessarily good and that's totally
cool
nicolas asked is there a shortage of
ammo with other characters as well or is
that just you know something with your
character using specifically so Jordan
played his um Mo's who has iron bear and
he he did like a melee build and he ran
out okay I already had that one you know
what's interesting as I started a new
game and it remembers a lot of your
stuff from the previous save so yeah oh
snap yeah
yes so Jordans here in the chat he did
not run out of ammo too much because he
mostly played a like a melee iron bear
build with Mo's so it was less of an
issue but with Zane I definitely run out
of ammo a lot okay
little tagline was sonic doom he really
does like his llama - all right come in
I mostly killed this guy the past couple
times I've played with TDR weapons by
just reloading constantly which means
your your weapon see like my weapon is a
grenade when I when I reload it so I'm
out of grenades but I basically have
unlimited grenades here great that's so
convenient sorry no I have two grenades
I was wrong that was a lie I just lied
all of you
so this fights mostly about avoiding the
dancefloor you know the boss fights in
this game are their bit spongy as was
pointed out in the review and I think
one of the larger issues Oh Jordan says
I played Azamara Aaron please he played
the bows bill all right he played
Azamara so he played a punchy and
marveled
but yeah if you go is iron bear with
Mo's there's a whole melee tree in there
and that lets you not use as my bullets
OOP
I'm seeing a lot of people saying they
want to play as flax flax really cool
he's got some fun familiars there hep
something something actually John Luke's
probably gonna put in our guide for
things you should know about this game
though is his pets are damn cute they're
really cute and they kind of ruin
cutscenes oh this goes back to me not
being a platformer player I do not play
platformers and any time a game makes me
like dodge things it just it doesn't
work you know you can sometimes you have
to have a certain skill set some things
that happen platformers is definitely
something you're born with
Hey and I wasn't either I'm like Liam
Neeson I do not have that particular
status
are all of the bosses part so the here's
the thing with the bosses
you know it's pointed out in the review
that a lot of them are bullet sponges
but that's not really the main issue the
main issue is a lot of them are bullet
sponges but they don't spawn ads very
often so when you go in to fight for
your life a lot of the bosses for some
reason don't have anything for you to
kill so you're just kind of done like
some of the bosses will just kind of
one-hit kill you or like kill you in one
garage and then unlike this boss fight
there's just no there's no minions to
kill so you can't revive yourself so
that was kind of the main issue in my
mind but that being said a lot of the
mid trees have self revive abilities so
for example Zane has halfway through
digi clone you have this one called old
you where as long as your digi clone is
active you can revive yourself oh cool
and earlier you like swap places with
him right
is that so that's the main the main
thing that he does up front is just swap
places which is actually really useful
for just getting away from attention
okay what's up crime good morning crime
says hey Aaron good to see you how are
you good see you too I'm playing a lot
of Borderlands I'm just gonna drop stuff
we're not gonna do the most efficient
route this time because I just want to I
want to play with weapons and all the
stuff that means I gotta get rid of
things in my inventory you do do a lot
of inventory management but you would
you would kind of expect that okay this
is the first kind of epic weapon you get
killing word fire sonic doom
see what they have to say
oh damn
so I offered the Sun smash it's a place
in our family she's a live streamer if
you haven't picked up on that
so yeah they are there the equivalent of
Pandora's you tubers
this is a flat off rifle which has an
under barrel shotgun so yeah the guns
are really fun this time around is so
crazy which is awesome alright we'll
spend our skill point and then we'll get
moving on the main mission
yeah what's next on the skills which one
are you going for next I think next is
talk to Lilith the talk to Lois kill
skill points okay so for Zane I usually
like to just invest in getting his clone
up for maximum possible time and then we
can immediately so if you look here
there's two slots you can induce skills
in so then you start equipping those
skills in those sub slots oh no
Zane is a guy who can actually do two
full skill trees I didn't particularly
think it was worth it in the first
couple of hours because you have to give
up your grenade slot but his his
portable shield is actually pretty good
particularly for playing with other
people and he can pick it up as he goes
okay we can teleport back cool he can
pick it up at any time and move with it
so he gives you kind of a good amount of
damage soaking ability fast trip hyper
flood says any music in the game strike
it as good catchy or memorable
ooh that's a really good question um I
guess I would ask you if you found
Borderlands twos music because do you
feel like it is it didn't go quite far
enough I just want to thank Sam Jordan
says the title screen music is
phenomenal and I'm not even joking a
little I'll sometimes just pull it up to
listen to you while I'm working nice I
I've gone as far as pulling up some of
the borderlands music on a running play
list when I go running because I think
it's awesome so yeah it is extremely
catchy I don't think we have to get in
the vehicle though are you just fast
travel to use our planets
unable to activate point of interests
nope no job says
want to play Zane's since the start
what's the pros and cons so Zane is a I
would have a hard time telling you cons
because I really like him I think like I
said I think the Considine
are a lot of his digi clone tree has to
do with grenades and the cut I think the
biggest con is just you being a danger
to yourself he is capable throwing out
so many grenades at any given time and
blanketing an area that if you don't
gtfo
we're like fall back using your clone
swap properly you'll murder yourself a
lot that's his biggest drawback I guess
you know if you want cute pets or if you
want to Titan basically then some of the
other characters a little bit better but
Zane's funny he's also kind of an old
man which you know the average gamer I
think is now in their 30s and I think
you it'll be easy to relate to him as a
character he's you know he's retired
he's already had a long illustrious
career this is kind of his retirement
plan he's really funny too he'll like
start wheezing he runs too much yeah but
he's still kicking ass so it's all good
he's the he's the good old man of this
franchise
Jenko san says hi GameSpot well hello
good morning
um I think a bent just asked does
Borderlands 3 support 4k I don't want to
answer that wrong but I didn't wait it I
work on a I think around 2k okay not
nothing
so yeah I'm like I'm almost completely
positive it does question is if your PC
can handle 4k
[ __ ] says I want to go to Pandora when
I hit midlife crisis go to Disneyworld
something right probably the closest
you'll get to it Ron Swanson says yes it
supports 4k that is a fellow member of
our chat who says that pretty much every
game on PC well every triple-a or
double-a game would at this point help
Taylor says how long does it take to
unlock all four weapon slots that's a
while it took me until I think playing
at three or four to get there but also
you know the nature of how we review
games as we sort of get through them as
quickly as possible
as opposed to there's a lot of really
great side missions so then the second
planet I can show you some of my skins
here the controller's a little bit weird
we can use like our marques head oh yeah
I'm going to show something off in the
menu she's the mouse is very like you
you're using your actual hand the
gamepad doesn't actually do everything
go wander bloodhound we got a lot of fun
skins I like my skin let's go back so
here's the interesting thing
you can emot-- using the z key on
keyboard but I have not found a
corresponding gamepad button yet
it might just not have been in our build
so the cool thing is we are currently
playing on PC you guys and then you can
reach back here pretty easily any time
you want
so yeah it's it's pretty easy to do what
a Vaughn he is ridiculous he's just like
a he's a bandit leader without a tribe
all right
get some sick splode Oh cereal jamming
did quite literally that's exactly what
it does okay what's next go to yridian
dig site we'll go make up with Tanis
so yeah sort of going back to that
question about how long it takes you to
get the third or fourth gun slots it
depends how many side missions you do
and the side missions are excellent a
lot of them on the second planet are for
ridiculous guns like the poop gun and
the hamburger launcher world 2 has such
a strong food theme it's just I was like
hungry the entire time Sabo says have
you tried high-level Moshe does her iron
bar damage scale well I only did it in a
preview event and I found I think it was
like mid game I found it did would you
want Jordan which one of us did play
iron bear since I couldn't I thought was
it jean-luc who started as iron bear
that moves with iron bear sorry Mario
says what's the framerate on consoles
but you guys haven't tried it yet on the
console we've only played on PC only had
the privilege of playing on PC what up
Tanis can you play the game Renzo this
drops on September 13 which is Friday
dun-dun-duh yeah and I heard it's gonna
be a full moon that day soon I suppose
there are certain types of horror in
this game Tanis has issues socializing
easy so can't wait so start a fortnight
MDR I mean the BR craze was definitely
super intense to be honest and let's be
honest we've all played plenty of
fortnight yeah like if you put fortnight
down now and never play it again believe
me you've played enough for tonight
I kind of feel like you know
single-player games are making a
comeback there's been more and more
announced lately so just so I can show
you guys so that's up this how the swap
works how many gigs is this game a scrim
it was around when I downloaded this
morning the early access build was
around 50 54 like 53 54 I had another
build that was more like 56 so yeah
somewhere in that range it's kind of
beautiful it is the killing word I love
oh you just cool it down with the score
again
yeah Grenada get knocked back man this
is so much better now I know what I'm
doing I remember these first couple of
hours also just randomly spawn digi
clone because fun yeah you know he's got
a pal the other cool thing with digi
clone is it's good for reloading so if
you if you over commit and you need to
fall back to reload digi clones good oh
you can also at any time I guess that
was the ability sorry there's a later
ability where you can just manually digi
strikes
I might I might avoid weapons where
we're scoped in all the time just
because it's kind of hard to watch when
you're streaming dingo asks has ammo
region made a return I know you're
talking about some guns that had like
automatic ammo regeneration there was a
gun that one of us found that auto
region demo but for the most part I have
not found weapons that do that I did
find when she's when she's active there
are certain pistols you're actually let
me do this really quick if I have the
pistol it's kind of funny but you can
stick you can stick a Taser to her and
then she runs around she runs around
doing extra damage yeah alright now when
she gets close to them oh my god July so
take it it's also kind of pioneering
cutscenes yeah you'll get them with your
taser it goes pretty far it's good yeah
now I'm not a pistol ammo so you like I
said in the early hours you'll see me
switch switch a lot cuz I do just run
out of ammo constantly it's good it I
didn't pick up an SMG that was a mistake
in the first couple hours you will run
out of ammo a lot so you want to make
sure to have a little bit of everything
on you oh my gosh hello there's seven
help that's all you need sometimes
exactly
Zachary's he says who has been your
favorite class so far I most will
actually have played as everybody but I
just really relate to Zayn but largely
because we're both old old gamers they
all have like it's not a it's not
necessarily even about power I think
they all just have really different
personalities and character and it's
more about which one you relate to it
just kind of determines you know how
much fun you have mediu sharukh says
what's the best class solo so I thought
it was flak because of the you know cuz
it is their familiars and like halfway
through one of their trees they can also
revive self revive but it turns out digi
clone can also self revive so it's
probably between those two like digi
clone is almost like having a it's like
having a digital pet that's you so
either of those two I think are really
good for soul oh self revive is key in a
lot of these boss battles as I mentioned
earlier the bigger issue is not
necessarily that the bosses are spongy
it's that for some reason a lot of the
bosses don't spawn and minions very
often so you can't get up from fight for
your life which is the larger issue and
key imagine if you could just do that
anytime you wanted disappear in a ball
of fire go to your favorite lunch spot
up here there in a ball of fire I mean
that might cause problems I know one day
one day
[Music]
she's upset she's a little coltie it's
her thing it's it's actually a pretty
good plot I mean the idea is basically
that all the bandits have just been
neglected for all these years
everybody's been either killing them or
ignoring them and the Calypso twins saw
an opportunity to just basically pull
all these disaffected bandits in and
give them a purpose and it it actually
makes a lot of sense and they're pretty
much using the Internet to do it which
is a thing these days it feels kind of
spot-on with the times Danny says is
this cross-platform I don't believe it
is like cross play or cross save well if
you look that up there's no cross play
that I'm aware of so the other funny
thing about this game is we're so used
to like we're so used to micro
transactions at this point but honestly
I had to stop and think for a second
when this game dropped this skin that I
could just use right away it like almost
weirded me out yeah that I could just
equip a skin that I had earned in-game
it reminds me of what it's like to have
a game that just lets you earn things
while you're playing sorry I fair
warning like I said the plot will
constantly be interrupted by me having
to switch weapons
[Music]
we're collecting biofuel to get
sanctuary off the ground we're doing
that by collecting bandits with our bus
on the front come here a bandits click
bio fuel by running over stuff I mean it
make sense how you go through that yeah
for all I think you have this massive
grill on the front can't go through that
I don't even know what it is tree or
something hives
Jenko says the graphics look amazing
exclamation point they do I think the
the graphics are good the movement is
the thing that really yeah they look
pretty good it's hard to go back to
Borderlands 2 and not have mantle and
slide GoGet or chip and then we can take
off yeah I keep seeing good comments and
then I look back the chat it's good Oh
how's the driving um is the driving the
same as previous games asks both Stephen
and Oakview the driving is there there
haven't been any major sections in the
game where it felt essential other than
getting from point A to point B more
collecting biofuel yeah collecting
biofuel it adds some flavor but didn't
feel it doesn't feel quite as important
as I don't remember the name of the zone
but there's like a desert area where le
was in the second game where it just
felt a little bit more built into the
world from a Mad Max vibe kind of way
how far you into the game asks team
unfortunately for this build we had to
start over but we've pretty much between
several us in the office that's pretty
much beat in the game so we can play up
to a certain points for you guys today
early access couple hours in we'll see
if we get there so yeah we're pretty
much towards the very start here and you
guys get a chance to really see a little
bit past this tutorial but not too far
in that it's in spoiler territory so
we're in a good place right now I feel
like we can go to the second planet and
there's actually a lot on the second
planet cool and like I said before it a
lot of it seemed around food and makes
you super hungry I'm ready cuz I'm
already hungry I had half a donut
offering yeah this is stream if you skip
the breakfast you're gonna be really
great on Planet 2 um Christian says ooh
all enemies constantly scaled to your
level now they do any if you pull well
no there's own sorry so they're there on
different planets that are definitely
zones but the answer is yes if you bring
a friend in so if you bring a co-op
buddy on your co-op buddy seamlessly
scales which is really cool you can
bring your your low-level friend in
who's just starting with your high level
character it's really cool you're both
legitimately seeing different different
levels over the enemies
so it's like adaptable but it's not
making it easier for the high level
person or more difficult for the lower
level exactly yeah the first time I
played though I you know there's a lot
of rng in this game and the first
preview then I went to I had a release
date of bad luck where over the course
of an hour I dropped a bunch of bad guns
and cycled through just running out of
ammo trying to kill higher-level
opponents and I definitely had to get a
farm farmers own so yeah no they don't
they don't necessarily scale to your
level so gross so we're searching the
toilets for money I mean the money and
the guns are always in the toilets
that's just a thing in this world
because you know who's gonna go looking
at the oil-- it exactly the last place
you'll ever uh I saw really awesome out
there there's a Dylan says are there any
raids on launched or do we have to wait
for DLC let's look that up cuz I don't
want to get bad information I know
there's it's already talked about DLC I
believe there was something Rea desk
talked about I don't want to get bad
info huh just got saved by the reload
got away from my digi buddy to come back
now so there's definitely gonna be DLC
they talked about that attacks and there
definitely will be raids but as far as
that happening on lunch all right we got
our nav so now we're gonna go to
sanctuary special bandits first
a lot of nurse said I think they said
something about Halloween DLC this feels
like the perfect game for some sort of
Halloween theme or you could just
confuse the hell out of a bandit by
switching back and forth
I was cryoablation khandhas and which a
sandwich abandoned and then explode back
and forth like that that's a good move
what were people whose favorite DLC from
Borderlands 2 out there
I thought Dragons kid was excellent it's
like tiny Tina role-playing adventure
it's pretty hilarious
Zach C asks how many times can you
hollow clone switch in a certain time it
seems though it seems I've maybe like a
1 or 2 second cooldown that's not bad
so this guy was the first vault hunter
and he left all these like funny audio
logs all over the place he's talking
about how in Pandora it's saying hello
to somebody just means whoever shoots
first
now these racks they never learn you
think at some point evolution would have
weeded out the ones that attacked fault
hunters and bandits a lot of the TDR
weapons also they make kind of funny
digital noises once you start reloading
first I went to get low in ammo all
right it's trying to get them off off me
city kid
take a look at you Ches what do you got
I don't I'm not a Jacobs guy no Rach are
you guys gonna stream Friday the 13th on
Friday actually I think Ben and John
Luke are gonna be playing some gears 5
multiplayer with you guys on Friday and
so if that's your thing make sure you
tune in on Friday although playing
Friday the 13th on Friday 13th does some
very fitting that is correct
returns bullets the magazine's so the
hyperion have a front shield oh I like
this one this one's fun
this one will reflect bullets back so
the Hyperion weapons all have different
shield effects some of them amplify
their damage and some of them just eat
bullets and some of them reload your
magazine some of them reflect bullets so
the the gun brands are very distinct
this time around like way more so than
in Borderlands 2
we're about to see some spoilers just
like a cutscene here so just be warned
snaps wail early spoiler alert if you
don't want to see a story
we're not allowed to destroy my ride man
the turn radius on that turret is pretty
good yeah nice to have a buddy in there
to see yeah we're gonna get a cutscene
here in a second
don't want to see it close your eyes
okay this is your last warning
this is really funny shiz
there's like have you see on her arm
there's a tribute to scooter everywhere
he died in the last game oh those her
brother he used to run the catcher ID
system so if you look at her arm right
there she has that and it's also on the
side of the ship okay cutscene incoming
Firehawk just give me the mat no way go
let's do this got it
[Music]
[Music]
you're a siren yeah well runs in the
family I'm the siren he's just a
parasites literally when we were born
our Father had to cut him off me now
I'm the only thing keeping him alive
what are you doing
I can leech the power from any living
thing even you fire huh
legendary vault
it's a lair of the destroyer Firehawk so
many titles a little impact well I've
taken your powers you might as well
finish you off ty ty Reed fine
[Music]
huh you should have seen your face
you were like Oh ty ty come on we're
live in three two
what is that brothers and sisters got
Queens I mean come of the alive we got
something real special for you today
your number one most requested murder
it's the great heretic herself the fire
Hawk well look who got what smile let's
give this Firehawk fingers tried but
that's not all our path to the Great
Falls has been revealed
next up bro maybe uh don't forget to
like follow and obey
don't feel bad lil all legends have to
die he had a good run I guess that's
just something people say I don't really
believe it
alright let's get out of here
I want to see if cata guy was good on
his word either scraps to the dogs
buh-bye now
thanks for the map and your powers I'll
make sure to finish what you started
later Firehawk or whatever you are now
she didn't forget to tell be able to
turn on and off vacations
ring the bell she missed that one
she missed the birth
now she's weak a saver I'm glad they
they didn't have to try to take the bell
notifications from you to because that's
there's just there's no there's no way
to tell somebody to do something to that
Bell that sounds good that's s this is
one of those oh my god do something
urgent player and then they're like wait
but stop collected oh yeah man so that
was a heavy cutscene I mean I haven't
played through this so I don't know what
comes next but that was heavy news and
I'm hoping we could save her still so
we can just as soon as we lose
everything on the way over there okay so
like it does that's good he knocked
himself over with his own shotgun
psychos nope that guy's got a rocket
launcher and I'm out of ammo as I
mentioned I wonder if I can reflect his
Rockets okay this might go badly but
yeah it totally worked
okay you need to take a nap take a nap
go to sleep go to sleep big guy I'm
starting to see some graphics talk and
chat but I feel like this is very
borderless like this style like they
manage to keep their style intact which
I think it's hard nowadays a lot of
people I think a lot of games feel the
pressure of being all what would
Borderlands look like without the shame
yeah
I don't like I we've definitely
co-workers and I have had a conversation
up here like would this work but
honestly you know I think they kind of
tried it with with rage and not wait was
there a team that just came out it was
it wasn't rage was yeah right sorry yeah
they try to with rage to unit I mean
there's a lot of elements to why that
didn't quite work but didn't quite work
who did you catch at and I'm out of ammo
but luckily I have all of my types of
guns SMG mo yep I got a semi GMO you
know I will say okay so like you know
not everything's perfect one one thing I
think is that sniper rifles and rocket
launchers feel really underpowered this
time around for some reason like rocket
launchers just don't do enough damage
for ya and also just for the low ammo
count they just they don't do enough
there is in the chatter saying I love
this style and it's very Borderlands
style grabs the perfect beautiful art so
you know I feel like they did a great
job
I appreciate games that done you know
don't feel the pressure whoa that was a
close one
good is you can swap
you just you know when you're playing
you should just be selling things
constantly see 6x3
but I'm just gonna just gonna throw
things away for now also I'm not not not
a headshot player so super appliances
they're so hot for this game I really
enjoyed it I mean I'm still working my
way through side content but honestly
this feels like the right Borderlands
game after the right amount of time off
like if you if you were huge fan of - I
don't know it depends on how much
pre-sequel you played but this feels
like just the right it feels just right
for when it's coming out
I love how the some the TV air weapons
like chase they chase him down
it'll actually run after him house
reload in front of you I'm too high
level yeah that's that's a good point
did he Fox he says art style is more
important to me than graphics alone yeah
there's a difference between graphics
and all right sighs so that's something
to think about to graphics I don't know
it's weird I feel like graphics are
something you only talk about now it's
there Oh pants if they're like
exceptionally good I don't know like
graphics this gen this gen the graphics
weren't that impressive
you know when the xbox360 came out the
ps3 they felt like high-end pcs and you
know it's particularly consoles kind of
started in the mid range this time
around I mean pcs a little bit of a
different situation but I feel like
graphics are only something you talk
about if it's some huge advancement in
general you just want to game that play
as well as it get lube and yet like what
was mentioned the chat just has a good
art style I don't know I guess being a
fighting game player
like graphics have very little to do
with how great the game could be so now
I just don't really that doesn't faze me
as much than other aspects of a game I
guess I'm also pretty low like low
maintenance I like easily satisfied like
gamer I kind of just like playing
everything so it's more of a semi-auto
sniper looks good there we go
that works get a boy Raheel says is it
an online game to an extent like you can
play with your friends and I could run
through no there will be raised soon I
believe you can play offline yeah I mean
like what game doesn't have those guns
look and are really nice cinematically
yeah we were talking about all the cool
ways you can reload the guns and how
they're you know how they work and stuff
like that so yeah like one of the
comments I commonly get when I'm playing
is you didn't pick up the best gun but
the truth is they're just it's hard to
not just pick up everything and play
with it I don't know like I just I see
something on the ground in a game like
this and I just I just want to mess
around with it and you know occasionally
you're running to a boss fights will I
see what this I think this one is the
bouncing cat I'm too distracted by this
gun did all right let's do important
things Willis
Lillith we finally made it to you sorry
we got this - you survived all that time
regardless man I want to like put her
over my shoulder and help her here we'll
do the next best thing will attach taser
darts to her while she topples zip
rocket nope okay here yeah yeah we can
protect her we can protect her this way
there you go
now nobody can hurt you you have a Taser
attached to your back picking up the
ammo yeah I mean if you're a mid max
player I'm sure you can come up with
some crazy building weapons obviously
they're just so much fun to screw around
with it's really hard - they are do not
just screw around oh yeah I'm so stuck -
Ellie okay you're down here right hello
accent
the other thing to do in this game
periodically is a you get the start
button and you get a social instead of
your regular screen this is your mail so
you you get guns in the mail as you
complete challenges these are from my
other character actually from my first
run-through so they're way too high
level for us but you can actually mail
these guns to your friends which i think
is kind of a cool little touch yeah so
if you got a best bud and you got a cool
gun you can just send it in the mail
oh that's a good point too Stephanie so
smooth gameplay content and proper
support for the game will always be more
important to me than graphics 100%
so yeah you'll see another tribute to
scooter here there's like a running
theme anything that Ellie does is a
tribute your brother
right in the field
so we kind of rushed through Pandora
there is pool anymore that you can do
and actually the game bounces you
between planets a lot so you'll find
yourself going back and forth pretty
frequently to do to do new stuff Lilith
is no longer a siren you're saying Terry
stole Lil's powers let's hunt down that
God Queen bitching damn rat back are you
crazy
I say we stay here and build a port to
claptraps point can we really take on
the Calypso's in our current state
terrines after the power of the vault
and there's no one else who can stop her
we have to get there first I may not be
a siren but I'm still a crimson Raider
we all are I'm with you through thick
and thin you know which ones which
string bang that's what I've been saying
certain death it is and I obviously
won't pass up a chance to study a new
vault alright let's get to it
we ride onwards to Promethea
hey lil bad luck to take a ship out of
orbit without a name she's already got a
name sanctuary
vault hunter over here I love her accent
heinous isn't wrong it's rain is more
dangerous than ever
she's got an army the map and my siren
powers gonna need all the help we can
get
claptrap what until do we have monster
media ah Prometheus a shining metropolis
and the home of the Atlas corporation
it's the most technologically advanced
planet in this arm of the galaxy I have
to convince them to help us find the
vault before the Calypso sister killer
plug-in that astronavigation so we can
what are you doing her face in the
conversation get the hell out of here
their return
look what you did I broke it the only
thing standing between this ship and
space is my name
thanks about that thanks but chat
it drives busting now that proportion -
until we get our systems online we're
dead in the sky Ellie how long is that
gonna take fast well hunter go check on
the rest of the crew see if anyone needs
help
claptrap keep your ass in that hole you
can count on me
you have one job father he's saving us
all with his Robo but praise be the Robo
butt
didja Fox says I'm wondering if the
writing is the same as Alaska hello
so they've tone it it's it's similar in
nature but they've put it down a bit so
like see it's not quite as often
okay we'll give you that little organ
oh geez
[Laughter]
it's a girl just got a sub in tariff
lash bags like a fleshy sleeping bag to
be fair the writers had her come out of
the front end on this one temperature
you should go see if anyone else
requires assistance I will contact you
if any other devices require punching
yeah I was gonna mention that I love how
it's like hey we need to save her slash
this machinery real quick it's usually
how you fix things justice says what's
good guys hey you prayer Joe what's up
just good morning and welcome thanks for
joining us today
then playing some Borderlands 3 we're
lucky enough to get some early access
today this PC but it's also gonna be
available this Friday everywhere
ps4 Xbox one and even Google stadia all
over the places it's goo when Spiegel
CDI uh I'm not a hundred percent sure
coming dude it'll come here that's some
go into Google City I'm gonna leave the
volume up a bit for the section just cuz
we're doing a lot of talking I'll turn
it back down once we start shooting
yeah no slaves for my prison cell turned
rooms nice okay so it's kind of what I
was talking about the very beginning
in-stream used to pick up a couple
things oh okay okay well thank you you
picked up some we left some good loot
behind
so like the loot the loot that you leave
behind Ivan you know I haven't found a
gun grinder I don't think it's in this
game but you do have this lost loot
machine and then okay so like here's a
problem in Borderlands right you have a
favorite gun it's become too low level
for the zone you're at and and you're
sad to let it go
you're not ready to let it go just yet
so you you can put it on a wall and look
at it forever
and then when you're you know come back
to your ship you can touch it and see if
it brings you joy and keep it or get rid
of it all right let's go talk to more
people Marcus I think this is yeah
that's probably part of the ship do
something
thanks but my firing range is still on
fire we're gonna fix this firing range
by shooting it
as you fix all firing ranges by doing
markers are fine gun salesman
while an entropy accelerator ain't no
thing got loads of spare parts in the
cargo bay and some special gear I was
Savin for you
it's kind of coming at me hard there all
right
where we go Nellie
she's so calm yeah there's just fire are
go back
well there goes the grapple grabber the
jetpack and all the left-handed guns
guess it wasn't meant to be
but if Earl didn't get sucked out into
the icy mild space he should have a
spare entropy accelerator yeah sorry
lefties that was where we lost all of
our left-handed guns in that scene well
yeah Earl this is the iridium purchasing
station so there's some extremely exotic
stuff here that you can buy for iridium
which you tend to collect more of later
in the game but these guns down here
that are in an Earl's basement of the
ship they also pair with your abilities
so that's an interesting question
sadboys says I need to know does this
game support ultra white have not tested
I don't give you a wrong answer an
entropy accelerator now scram
I don't see your name on the door
whatever your name is
hand out for that partner I'm gonna
twist you into a pretzel and fondue your
ass fair enough I'll give it to you you
had something worth my while but you
don't so get lost free load up early
been a day amigo
missed me you ain't got WAP no no she's
about to go hammer him in there tight
maybe you had some more iridium he'd be
willing to trade bribery oh that's right
her mom's her mom's Moxie isn't it I
totally forgot about that that's like
more Skeeter yeah more scooter he's he's
everywhere now yeah al Cowen's and press
f to pay respects a scooter can cook all
ahilla claptrap yeah that's how I'm
feeling great scooter is memorialized
everywhere that's a nice though so they
didn't like forget about yeah sorry guys
we had to cut the camera for a sec cuz
we were experiencing some technical
difficulties
but we're getting the names moxy
what's your sugar nervously no did you
forget me guilty as charged
[Music]
have you tried my slots maybe you'll get
lucky as you can tell the writing is a
very highbrow oh yeah play the slot
[Music]
well would you look at that you've got
the magic touch come back any time sugar
I've got a few other games we could play
hey she means she means literally she
literally wants you to play her game you
guys will recognize this if you yeah
like it's same as bort oh please call it
rollin wow that's a throwback yeah if
you tip you start getting she'll start
sending you things in the mail no that's
a throwback from - hey I'm head
reflexively heading back man my home you
know it's funny but one of the hardest
things to go back to Borderlands 2 is
just not having the slide a slide just
feels so necessary protected I don't
have enough iridium yet for anything but
yeah so like if you go to down the
Earl's basement in the sanctuary he has
weapons that pair with your abilities
oh cool that one dude 702 says whoever
asked about ultra wide Borderlands 2 did
ultra wide so I imagine this does - yeah
I just don't want to make up an answer
we just haven't tested it yet I've
actually only ever played on an ultra
wide monitor one
it's super cool it's also if you're like
a so one cool little touch is when
you're warping to new planet if you
quickly run back here you can see it the
whole ship you can see like you warping
through the whole ship it's a really
nice little touch
that immersive feeling
still stuck with his butt
[Music]
[Music]
their production value say that editable
better get out of here for real this
time
take us to premedia I said most of your
desire to kill them is out of how
obnoxious
I think somebody asked earlier they said
can you save multiple finally you can
yeah this is a this is a new character I
started on the same build another the
same build site on the same account and
some of the things transfer over like
your skins transfer to your new
character I think someone else also has
asked if you could put a gun on the wall
and then pick it up with another
character or is it autistic songs you
know I haven't tried it but I don't see
what would stop you from doing that you
can also mail guns you can put them in
the vault which probably let you do the
same thing listen about what happened on
Pandora we can't let anything slow us
down you're gonna have to pick up the
slack for me can I count on you I got
your back commander good now let's make
contact with that listen if anyone knows
where the vault is it's them I like how
it wasn't yes or no just to talk I have
a guy do you have any signals from that
battle one must be jamming their clothes
all right
yeah
sounded like an atlas distress call they
need help down there getting Atlas on
our side would be a good start to
finding the vault here we can back them
up maybe they'll help us at least not
kill us recharge coming from the city I
can get you down to the surface we don't
have access to the Promethean fast
travel I'm just helping to recharge her
powers yeah you know she's still
recovering she pretty much eats iridium
for breakfast so it makes sense that
electricity without there's nope
I'm lost on my ship oh no slow mo says
there's supposedly thousands of Gundam
I mean it's randomized actually one
thing I can show you to answer that
question is when you customize a weapon
so with some of the more exotic weapons
when you go to customize them oh yeah
that was something I wanted to see - you
can see sorry not customized you can't
swap out parts but you can see ok yeah
mark in his junk they're gonna inspect
and then when you flip over this shows
you all the parts that get randomized in
the game so these are all things that I
believe just when it rolls loot each of
these is each of these is just randomly
rolled for example some of the barrels
just come up as alien barrels and then
they have a giant alien face on them or
a giant alien mouth so yep all these
parts are randomized and then you can
yell a summary of what it does and what
it's good for so yeah they're there
they're probably I don't know how many
combinations are it's
too many humane accountant
taupey we are playing on PC right now
Brad so I rigged up or drops coffin
coffin cat says actually it's a billion
civilian guns technique that's what the
market billion we're safe by any measure
except these two hands you've been
checking out anyway get in and I'll
lunch she's so cute I saw you she is a
great character yeah I love her so much
I think the real the real answer to that
question is how many good guns are there
[Music]
that looked like a rough ride you still
with us killer worst thing that ever
happened to me
let's do it again so we can go up to a
mission called under this planets and we
can't show that but that's a while down
the road yeah we can still got a good
amount we can show and then we can do
all the side missions here including oh
I never figure out where to get the poop
gun maybe John Luke I want to see the
poop gun maybe John Luke can help us out
in the chat there's like a there's a
hamburger
I want to rape these hamburgers
so hyperion are the calypso twins
corporate sponsors tod the sounds on
these guns are actually really excellent
yeah yeah they all do have their own
[Music]
Luke please if you're in the building
guide us see the to scuttle monsters
family Daffy Duck glue I thought a few
people asking about split-screen for
this game
I haven't seen anything I thought it I
thought I read about every we haven't
tested it Adam a no your favorite three
words eight by ten underbarrel I mean
tell me that little bug I've had this
big ol gun I don't know where he was
I like that it makes all the enemies
target your clone to meet shield lots of
utility I don't know if a clone can be a
good boy but yeah I don't know how to
answer that that be like petting
yourself that in the privacy of your own
home totally fine just know petting the
clone in public okay so we are skilling
up this happens a lot in this game
you're like in the middle of a firefight
you're like oh I gotta spend some skill
points so this is the one that makes me
fire a grenade randomly which is awesome
let's do that I'm always on me some
random needs why not heaven says the gun
sounds wicked already heck yeah and
[ __ ] says how does the gun play feels
at least something looks a bit pretty
good no they feel really good
we're playing TC with the controller it
feels very excellent I think the guns
are you know like previously Borderlands
game Berlin Sims maybe they put a little
bit loose they feel very very dialed in
and tight you can pet flax pets like me
you've got some good timing these
bandits somehow got their hands on some
wicked mallow wand guns oh right I'm
Lorelei dude resend you grease no clue
sorry my boss CEO of Atlas we're at war
with mal Awan not from around here are
you
now all these maniacs show up all over
the city screaming about some vault
that's thought scallops or shy Pez and
trying to beat them to evolve myself the
Calypso's those yammering echo net our
souls with the cult well I've got those
slagging clue about bolts but Rhys would
know who come on I got to tell him about
our new bandit problem anyway I'll
introduce you
so at this point in the game Sonic game
lay perspective why the enemies pick up
shield ready so you're gonna want to
switch over to weapons with their
effective against shields seems like
there's a lot of shielded enemies in the
game from this point forward I think it
was above my level so I can't oh that's
all right sorry
soon soonish a lot of pistols in this
game okay and let's go the shotgun and
then we will continue with talking right
some wheels we need to drive through the
spillways and there's always trouble so
every every vending machine has a deal
ok so it's good to stop by the vending
machines like pretty frequently and it's
a good way to if you don't have good
drops it's a good way to just pick up
stuff tink says I'm trying to decide
between Shane and those I think I'm
gonna go score what well tell me what
you're interested in yeah what do you
want to do with your character yeah
alright it's just so I'm just gonna self
as lower level stuff to get me fire
inventory it's funny a lot of these guns
look great on paper and then the minute
you start shooting em you know don't
like burst fire okay can you turn on
subtitles would that help people out
gonna chat guys want some subtitles we
can make happen I mean I am actually
subtitles even watch really
Connecticut's and stuff
steal on our attack
these bandits have some nerve what's up
Ken hello
thanks for joining us checking out some
Borderlands brews spin pretty snazzy so
far yes we're good
Borderlands 3 drops us Friday you guys
on Friday the 13th if people in the
chatter serious I can turn all of
seriousness
[Music]
Oh Dave poor man yeah they're doing like
some mind-warping stuff now passwords
open the bloody door before I shove a
coffee grinder up your ass actually can
October is gonna be a huge FTC month so
I was gonna ask you come on down this
way next month there's an Atlas Base
nearby with a direct line back to Reece
and HQ palawan captured it a few months
ago I haven't had the manpower to take
it back but now that you're here maybe
we can finally send those bastards
packing oh the chat is super serious
about some subtitles okay oh by the way
I think there's like TVs where they play
the little propaganda all over the world
oh geez
just to make you extra mad options new
visual visual windowed borderless feel
the view oh we can turn that up I'm not
gonna try it today cuz danger overall
quality shadows dance nope nope all
control we play Oh uncensored gore
yeah leave that leave that
wouldn't be network and social
accessibility here we go I need to read
menus okay sure
Wow Mouse 80s snaps a target there you
go
subtitles oh okay I love that it was the
last like one of the last options on the
whole menu but boom we got it since I'm
so tired
yep fighting all I want is a decent
night's sleep
see these civilians mother one doesn't
care if they're caught in the crossfire
they're here to take over outlets and
sell Reese's new weapons as their own to
them this war is just a merger let me
know when you're ready to take back the
Atlas base yes
I'm letting you know
it's not easy you know go from barista
to guerrilla fighter overnight
who knows maybe someday you'll get to
meet the real me you know it's me that's
got nothing to do with a war
yes I'm ready one second
we may not have the numbers but this is
follow Lorelai she is stop walking right
so we're doing side mission are we
studying mayorships
to mellow on guys look at this they know
we're approaching the point in which it
could no longer show off the game family
but we could still squeeze down a bunch
of side missions before we get to that
point which is the upside man look at
these cases these guys both suck ass
which means we can't trust either of
them you got to figure out who killed
who if I'm gonna get my revenge malla
want troops stomping all over my bloody
neighborhood makes me sick
I could really go for a coffee right now
yes really go for a coffee right now
yeah you may not have the numbers but
this is our home you know you got
something close to a party yeah that
works before
Oh
I love juggling people a socket is so
good
86 or other ones never come down here
before if they think we're easy targets
now that they've got bandit back up oh
they're about to learn differently
come on Oh
I kind of shrugged off two grenades it
goes nothing
stinky mother want bloody
well-entrenched so get ready for a fight
this is mission yeah we're good we got a
little ways to go okay cool and like I
said we can go do the poop gun and all
the fun stuff I know we have to find the
poop gun I haven't done the poop gun yet
I really want to do the poop gun or at
least a burger gun I'd be satisfied my
loved ones even more satisfied if we ran
into bowls I'm just clearing it's a
question about how the game feels a
little bit earlier honestly it's just
real good I really really like how this
game feels yeah you know we were talking
about how it's been such a long time
since - right but I feel like take all
the time you need if it produces
something like it's beautiful is it
honestly it it just it feels really
smooth and fluid in a way that makes you
realize the previous borderline games
were a bit Yankee
oh man run and gun run and gun the combo
bloody did you stop a dose last time we
streamed somebody had an issue with us
running away from anything and not going
to fight for your life and now we're all
in this this will go well nothing can go
wrong I just like making a big like
eSports week's for every game that we
play don't be alive easy solution
Hey
I know that's took forever out of ammo
glass in the shotgun
oh yes cover nice oh dang you have a
sealed bag up
little breather Oh Oh combat breather
here we go
yeah this one is definitely super dope
and the more we level it up the more
like amazing a good I like our objective
is like go to the murder scene
although we're just leaving a whole
trail of murders in our wake get over
there with all the murderers like which
murders
two murders naked murder he didn't die
did it okay okay I was looking through
him oh we got this guy to deal with yes
there will be rates in borderland
I don't know which is worse Barbie
out of ammo yes
yeah Miranda in the Santa
vamo all right where's our ammo we got
SMG ammo
okay of all these guns like can't use it
I threw away my SMG didn't I
you got sniper rifle out of ammo wait
that's not a sniper rifle it's a regular
rifle all right we're just gonna have to
cry Oh Nova him to death this is gonna
go well here yep Pro Nova for the win
oh dang
it works alright we're gonna back off
and pick up some ammo
give me the ammo give me ammo I got
eight bullets pawlenty you send your
thoughts and prayers head shots only
my dude is also shielded alright we're
going to think creatively so that's
electric let's go with our I tossed it
Dhoom penguin says are the class months
the same as always you pick them up much
later in the game this time
shot Aldi
this is some of the things that you use
you're used to picking up earlier in a
Borderlands game they kind of hold off
until later
I love that for
so juggernaut to show up big old
cheer-off yeah we got 32 rounds got new
rifle rounds 21 pistol rounds oh yeah
are these hands vending machine behind
there was a vending machine right hang
on guys I gotta make a quick run to the
store
hold that combat thought yeah BRB don't
go anywhere
goodbye am I gonna buy ammo that's cheap
I guess I have to buy ammo dang it
we also have a ton of money we can buy
back buy back yeah we needed an SMG
alright we're gonna buy ammo we're gonna
splurge we're gonna spoil our show
I just bought a thousand dozen taller
than ammo and I don't feel good about it
what are you doing Lorelai get in there
she's a barista she's not like fully
used to this
oh man how can feel so good
yeah juggle him like a balloon
was it his foot oh sorry
[Music]
see I didn't punch that one Dorian says
I could live in this game as long as I
have the hamburger gun I think that's
you make myself burgers all day Jude she
does not care for her life
we want to teleport in there right now
yeah the clone kind of had a group take
the heat for us
good Glen as the fire pistol and they
are super resistant to fire all right
what do we need we need electric it's
not called electric but that was Freya
what is going okay and killing word and
remind me to never throw away my SMG
again
oh boy
the rains on that shaggin alright one
down one to go
this guy is just taking a stairway to
heaven you go with job buddy
sometimes vegan the bosses would be in
the sweet spot
Siberian shotgun has been seriously
doing work okay before we talk to
anybody we're gonna go buy an SMG Oh
give me time to buy step okay I gotta
buy stuff just wait right there Lorelai
okay SMG nope nope nope nope yes great
names are gonna be a slightly higher
level but we're getting there no we're
not we're nowhere close that was level
12 so I have noticed guns drop pretty
far above your level in this game it can
I don't know if like it's designed that
way to encourage you to back off and do
more side missions on other planets but
it does seem to restrict your ability to
progress sometimes
by the way um so when you're in the game
I'm just using the d-pad but you can
actually flip flip your missions just a
quick question
Caroline Rhys relax it's Lorelai we've
taken back watershed base with a little
help
I've got hang about what is that thing
on your face oh this this is my seat
mustache
guess I'm a vault hunter no mana crimson
Raider and a handsome bastard I'm a lot
of things crazy
holy crap yes 20,000 50,000 you don't
need all this I'm a one-man our murder
what city with a single-digit
army they're good Reese really good and
we need all the help we can get
bandits are pouring into the city and
they're working with Milan looks like
cat Seagal was made a deal with the
Calypso's my top age is gearing up to
strike at mallow on strategic [ __ ] mind
if they are after the vaults that's
where the Intel will be go meet up with
my agent Reese out right nice now well
you go mitrice's agent I'm gonna get
this base back online and start securing
more of the city well before you head
off I've got something for you
is it again yay presents that's a
vehicle now since you're heading down
look outside it's fast and light perfect
forgetting about the city streets take
it for a spin
it's the wheel vehicle wheel
what do you say we start civilizing this
well this time a multi-player coffee I'm
feeling right ragged and when a
commander makes mistakes people die and
I'm sure my troops could use a
pick-me-up as well head to the rise and
growing coffee shop to get started so
you can fight your friends at any time
there's like a Dueling mode hmm and you
can do it for loot apparently dang I'm
dropping I don't know if this is because
I have another character here but I'm
dropping stuff way above my level like
this is level 23 and I'm level 9 right
now I honestly I might as well trash all
this stuff oh maybe I picked up some of
the stuff from my mail I don't know
where came from but lightning I might as
well trash this stuff because I'm
there's no way in like this stream I'm
gonna get to a point where I can use it
just go ahead and sell I marked it as
junk so I can just sell everything you
know I might not be able to buy weapons
on this planet there's a question
earlier about scaling we'll see it might
have scaled above my level already
because of your other character unknown
I know when I was playing before I
definitely did have characters I sir
have weapons drop maybe like two or
three above my level we'll see what
happens
[Music]
I'm sure you two will hit it off just
grand
it sounds natural oh she was serious
about the I need a coffee no she's very
serious I respect that I feel the same
way hey Boyle need a cup of our cheery
and super black of course it's okay
right
there's a heavy calls himself daddy like
a real bugs got a power core built right
into his suit that'll get us up and
running power cores there's always their
damn power cores isn't it a lot of
wearing for a cup of coffee but it's
necessary
[Music]
I'll pick up some side missions while
we're at it yeah kill kilovolt that's
hosting a
we need some coffee
monk died
he does do not want to teleport back
into that yeah we had to let the clone
oh man I thought I'd drop the shield
earlier all right out of ammo
your constant state of being it is a way
of way of existing dangerous copy all
for the caffeine I'm not even mad I've
been out I should not fight for your
love thank you mate where's that little
guy
alright it's alright we got we got lives
we got connections someone earlier in
the chat was mentioning if you shoot at
those orbs on their back wave die faster
this is probably true the chat always
makes a secret check $600 for dying what
a deal
Wow oh now I'm actually being attacked
from Oh
dismantle your vehicle
that was a kiss things were happening
that was a gift in me destroyed
oh we like this area not the best place
these guys just really like the copy I
gotta focus on one of them at a time all
right shoot the ball good job jack yeah
problem is there's three of them
shooting at me no no no gunfire
see this what I was talking about
earlier there's just not a lot of like
in a lot of these boss fights - just not
a lot of minions around so you run out
of you go in to fight for your life and
you run out of ammo and you're in
trouble we could probably do we could
probably do a side mission and and level
up a teeny bit more because otherwise I
might get second that Luke or you just
keep running out of ammo yeah let's go
do the mission about so you can't
necessarily step back in our base you
can't necessarily just plow through the
game so that's not here that's somewhere
else kilovolts a bit above our level
here we go murder scene we could
definitely do this being rude I'm just
trying to summon our vehicle here
you know what if I can cheat hey use the
vehicle now as a barrier Laura
good noona cheese sometimes he probably
has a mod on that
our vehicle smokin would in your AI okay
so go to the murder scene still making
our way to that murder scene
we'll do a couple of side missions first
and I'll come back because otherwise
we're gonna fight three heavies with no
Anna
[Music]
nuki get in that way
oh snap rich says thanks for confirming
GameSpot I did the right thing by
pre-ordering mmm this is the burger
place I wonder if I can Oh Burger gun
half sitting here I don't know if I can
kick off the mission beforehand but
let's try that's right
[Music]
get up alright stupid planet
even says why are you using to action
skills with Zane have been long time I
can do that for you the next one it's
because the second skill gives up the
grenade
I'm all about the grenade life but I'm
happy to the next level up will put it
into the shield and I can show you how
that works cool but yeah that's the
that's the biggest drawback to that one
what am I missing you told me to go here
yes we're good always do your side
quests yeah we're gonna try to check out
as many of the side quests as possible
we are officially allowed to play up to
a certain point so we're gonna try to do
as much as we can before we get to that
mission so you guys check it out I think
the issue is more where because we
haven't done all the side quests we're
just gonna go in through this we've
probably gotten a little bit ahead of Wu
where we can feed based on our level
so we'll like for example that that
fight was it basically against three
heavies and we didn't really have the
skills or the ammunition to do it
huh distraction actually young close I
like the technical more than I like the
fast vehicle I just think it's just
better for dealing with guys the fast
ones good if you're if you're just
trying to avoid everything
yeah if you're gonna get scrappy this is
the trek for you
[Music]
J says nope PvP is energy a problem I
don't really feel that way because I
don't think that's a major draw in for
this game specifically like Borderlands
is in a very specific place and they've
stayed within that place see if there's
any clues these brothers are arguing
over who's the more prolific murder
my guess is neither of them committed
them
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I honestly don't know my family just
pick one to kill I guess Oh consider
that my payback I trust your judgment
who are we choose in chat racks or max
let's let the chat decide while we're on
our way to do the deed
[Music]
um what is the level up limit I think of
what aura is asking Jordan in our office
has gotten for this that is a good
question I'm not sure they used in the
thirties but I don't know what the mass
what it is few other than chatter
singing they heard the level hat is that
basically when you get the end of the
game there's big clove another new game
plus mode oh I feel like we got two
votes for max few votes for axe
two votes for bull with more more rax
both more max good man you guys are like
lit right in huh can we kill those
seeing a lot of votes for Bowls
odds gaming says how would you guys
compare Borderlands 2 to this it just
plays way smoother it just made a lot of
improvements in the way the game feels
and the humor
it's interesting the humor is still
similar but it's not constant in the way
that it was in previous games I guess I
think some people you know claptrap was
a love or hate thing for a lot of people
and he's very toned down in this game
alright I'm starting to see way more
votes for racks now on Macs
well maybe if you told your henchmen air
in your life your life there's actually
minions around this oh man I love the
annoying class that berries it's not as
prominent you saved us with just but
earlier what more can you ask
we're hurtin but we're living nice that
guy's mad why Sam a drove we're good
accuracy
not back dreams of that night that's
true he does look very bad address whoa
ha ha he's got punted oh we can get back
in there
and this guy really Sabbath
chill man chill what the knife alright
Julian says ask I don't know if y'all
know or not but do you know if they kept
any Legendary's from previous games like
snipers or anything I haven't seen any
haven't seen any returning weapons yet I
mean there's some things are in the
spirit of those weapons like weapons
that talk to you and things like that
but I haven't seen any direct returns
did you have a favorite ooh that's like
way better but slower delay now what we
need it
alright we finally found an SMG
[Music]
yeah Aaron Xena's definitely oh there's
holes in the bottom
oh nice thanks clone this is why we have
clones because we keep falling off of
high places
that barrel took a lot more hype hearing
weapons are like charged rifles they
take a little bit of time to spin up
you're dead right she did
don't be alive we're getting close the
place where I can show you two skills at
once yeah it's useful you just lose
grenades but to be honest on this run I
haven't really found that many awesome
grenades so that works got some tiny
Tina talk in the chat
Dumbledore says I hope tiny to Yuna has
a bigger part in this game I can I mean
I can say that she's in the game and she
is not as tiny she used to be let me
show you this real quick so this is how
you actually upgrade your vehicles it
most of us had played quite a bit of
this game until we realized how this
worked so you actually have to go steal
vehicles and bring them back to your
catcher ed and that is how you upgrade
your vehicles just to be sure
bill cloud chasin even after his bro
lacked he's next it's gonna maybe snipe
him that last day I was pain
alright gotta kill the other bad guy he
just showed about an it or in the same
spot how weird he down below where you
at other murder brother
I feel like Max was definitely stronger
my clone just picked a fight with a
vehicle all right so we're gonna go
steal a ride we're gonna take it back so
I can show you gone in 60 seconds
your choices matter in the sense that
it's funny how many weapons can you
carry with you equipped up to four but
it takes you a while to unlock the four
slot and your inventory you you upgrade
in sanctuary over time I mean I guess
the amount of time depends on how much
money you want to invest in it
hello tunics what is that thanks for
joining us today we are playing some
Borderlands 3 got our hands on it a
little early Aaron and a few others in
the office have been playing a lot of
this actually Jordan who I believe is
still in the chat also is level 37 also
played a lot of Borderlands 3 so we were
actually pretty excited we got to share
it with you guys early news these guys
have been playing quite a bit of it okay
so upgrading your vehicles you got to
steal these these ones that are in blue
on the map for some reason a bunch of us
in the office took a long time to forget
this out so you got a feel like a lot of
them are actually a lot of them are
platforming puzzles
back at you Elwin sorry if the Rose
Tech's explosive texts all right where's
our catch rides back on the other side
take a cruise
[Music]
so anyway yeah if you see these on the
map a lot of the collectibles are on the
map at all times so you gotta can I keep
your eyes open
catch Ram have you found any secret
chest off cliffs lately there's there's
definitely like Borderlands 2 there's a
lot of places you can climb to and you
will often find chests if you if the
weight borderlands games typically work
and still work is if you think you're
being clever and climbing somewhere
there's usually the developers have you
usually put a chest there already they
know what you're trying to do return to
zip Oh get your payment yeah for
avenging her family okay there was a
question about dual wield weapons but
Jordan said that there haven't been any
as far as he's found so far I swear I
saw a tooltip about it but I haven't
personally encountered do wield
oh it's been skill points okay so the
chat asked if we could get rid of our
unfortunately as you know this leads you
getting rid of your grenade where are
you use if you're you're like way over
here that's because it was like one of
those quests okay I might have enough
now to go do the thing we wanted to do
so let's I don't know if this sticky
bombs arm is better but let's try it
okay my vehicle and for the requests in
chat so Zane has two skill trees he can
equip let's equip barrier to slot two so
unfortunately this gets rid of our
grenades which is one of the main
reasons why I didn't do it before I
recommend in your early playthrough not
doing it just because of that but you're
welcome to give it a go
[Music]
it also seems like the last skill and a
lot of these skill trees aren't that
important so if you want to branch out
oh it
Thank You Prince I had two skill points
yay nice so we'll keep going down this
tree then grenades that's what that's
all about
after playing grief all lately I feel
like I get really excited over skilled
Oh stop shooting my ride
that is not how I get up there
where did you go Hyrum
we might have to leap back around
through the bad place
but we did get win on the rations front
today skyman we're fair had actually get
here oh it might be like way you might
be telling us to go to another zone I
think turned as if here we go it is
telling us to go to another zone maybe
I'm gonna drop pod yeah whatever yeah
favoring packets so we're in the soup
for a few weeks
no bloody noodles though I've got so
many people looking to me for a plan but
I'm still figuring out what to do with
myself I had plans there just when also
very is when malla want started melting
down I say sure I could still walk into
a quick-change booth and come out a new
bloke but there's a bloody lot more to
it than just distracting a new body
maybe once Meridian safe
it was like neither coffee they need to
do their buttocks
we definitely need to kill poor daddy
but poor daddy kind of has other ideas
but our shield might actually save us
this time what yeah that was like one
hit and then I started going down all
right many minions come on give me some
minions
not happening no all right we're gonna
do it both cordetta we've hit that boy
in the stream we're core daddy is just
blocking our progress all right we got
this oh yeah we just have to not get hit
at all
HD says buy ammo capacity can you do
that we can we'd have to go back at the
sanctuary which is actually not hard to
do we'll do that I can show you that I
think that would be useful in this fight
yeah if we have the cash let's see if
you have the cash that's a good idea
it's hard sometimes to like remind
yourself yeah I could just go up to
sanctuary at any time I'll go visit
Marcus
no loss leads Marcus was up here to the
right
[Music]
okay we use a lot of rifle 5,000 oh okay
okay
then all of our money in one place
doesn't also mean when I die I don't
have enough money to respawn and we're
gonna hang up hang up some of our guns
because it's not working anymore or
asked skins for guns how do you get them
they hmm I can show you where you equip
them I'm not 100% sure where they came
from to be honest so cool we can hang up
our favorite gun then we're not gonna
use anymore the bill that we had came
with one skin and I honestly don't know
if it was just a pre-order thing or not
oh snap happy birthday tunics thanks for
spending a portion of your birthday
hanging out with us playing some
Borderlands day so change skin so yeah
this is the only other one that we had I
will say that you earn a lot of stuff
just through playing also check our mail
while we're here no call see if maybe
any better guns came in no these are our
two high level because they're from our
other character all right we're gonna
give this a go again all right
those Korra daddies are going down I've
got to get this coffee seriously man
we need that coffee okay
sit still core daddy yeah god dammit
core daddy I'm like at the point of
wanting to cheese it somehow or we yeah
alright well give it another go we got
this I believe anywhere the problem is
he hits you and that hit does damage
over time so you can't get away
which is why I'm curious if I can lower
him down lure him down to a vehicle well
just try to use the environment whoo
this one actually fires up and over so
what do we trigger him
[Music]
because we couldn't exactly drive up
there last night
time for your best cheese strats
will our idea work I don't think not
quite good though
coffee matters that is correct or a
coffee but now we have the two abilities
right at my elbow
oh man okay coming over here we're just
trying to fight Oh daddy's cheese strat
for the wind that is how you jeez what
more could you ask for it works it's not
our fault Cora daddy walks over here cor
daddy was not the brightest daddy turns
out cor daddy you know thinking is just
not as strong see whatever I want to
stick around alright let's go get that
coffee
when in doubt geez
what do you think about flack asks
Dillion it's got some good boys Oh
dragon hat yep get it put in the green
thing exactly
give him the court give me the coffee
did you know some people are from other
planets true that go to event I command
you
Coffee jordan says Aaron's good taking
on a mission like two levels under your
levels that's why we had to implement
cheese strats to help us balance that
find John Luke and ask him what the poop
gun is yes please we need to find the
poop gun I think the burger gun is next
see if you can track him down get his
mug
give me that milk nope that's my parking
garage now where the mug is where's the
mug
look through here alright everything is
nice and close commander that mug is
mine
she's so serious about it I love it she
she is literally deadly serious about
this really cool you can take out the
seals
commander bring us your mug and no one
else has to get hurt
just kidding everyone's going down
so if our shotguns have been pretty good
for punching above your weight see now I
don't have any grenades
slow travel time on this SMG I got 18
way ahead of where you want to be all
right nope got a guy was behind us he
was not
you sing go Susie Nakul I haven't found
any good at the outlets guns are worth
that when it comes to I'm definitely a
little bit low level but we've got high
level skills so another core daddy oh no
we need our vehicle get that Eric right
daddy
yeah they screaming for tonight
poor daddy was a specific core daddy but
we'll just call them all for daddy whoa
all right Greg you're gonna have to
relax
also this SMG just isn't that great
[Music]
hold back heavy gunner daddy
Ana's they could just be else--if at
this essence you just ain't that great
let's go back to our we had a get Vlad
off a second ago
good rifles make up for a lot let's see
what does less damage you know some of
these also feel like they just punch
their armor better
zero this we definitely died a couple
times for the quarry daddy but it's all
good
in the name of coffee
uh-huh no that's not doing any damage
that guy's all right we need a Jacobs
Jacobs are good for crits
and we're only on fire today bad yet
- good
oh dang
I got a rocket launcher although
actually I didn't mention they're one of
the things that I think are really under
level this game get out that's how you
get out I didn't get through yeah
what an arm
not another cord yep sonic or daddy's we
only have a hundred more truth till
Jacobs are actually real good at
punching above your weight sir Jacobsen
shotgun all right good we got our mug
that was it was all for a mug just just
so you remember we got our mug good okay
so um this is what you're talking about
before it you don't actually Williams
those black is John wick because he has
pets
maybe a little different although I've
been seeing John wick three
I love the first two and I really loved
John wick PR you guys just let us out of
here
we were just here for the mug just here
for the copy guys come on I mean I am
normally this deadly serious about
coffee
but come on within reason you gotta kill
him
I'm gonna steal our economy I was gonna
share real quick so I'm not impressed
with the rocket launchers they kind of
wanted to show that off hopefully I'm
wrong like a flame thrower like that
gunk gun poison
get over your coffee runner yeah give
[Music]
Ike I know what like a real-life mug now
that looks like that commander come on
the number of people who have died for
this coffee are probably worth it
I mean imagine your planets under siege
and you can't have coffee I imagine you
would want to kill that horse yeah I
think we hit like a deadly apocalypse
I'd probably try to stock up on coffee
instant coffee the world will never be
the same if coffee stopped existing I
don't even want to think it's not a
possibility
I'm an excessively drive across the
street there's multiple things I love
about this mission right now
it's a mix of like all-out war over this
mug oh they're very serious and there's
only one mug everywhere I already oh and
I need to see John McCrae desperately
for so many amazing forms of
entertainment out now
oh this can look good on paper but
actually stability is real bad also a
good point chat about shooting the
shooting the thing on top it definitely
does
I can get this thing to walk in right
all right we're good now for Indy and
follow your dream don't let your dreams
just be dreams and make them a reality
we're doing big damage to these gunner
daddies now that is so cute
Shawn gray says waited so long for this
my three year old too tight she did the
christmas dlc by herself
and with death job that's awesome i I
also started playing through two with my
kids although I made the mistake of
starting as Krieger which which was a
bit much so I went back picked up some
the main characters but yeah Borland's
is honestly for kids if you're worried
about you can turn the door off too I
think there was a setting for it mine
no the coffee is mine
oh yes been in the chat also your toy
said yo I heard about dreams
alright I'm ready for the special Merlin
three thermos city release that looks
exactly like this and they could easily
put that meter on the side cuz you know
they have the color-changing like it and
like all of the things you're saying
right now
[Music]
she really really want that gobby I feel
that Thunder bracelet it was we're not
gonna make her wait we're just gonna
fast-track what's your oh there's a
psycho part god damn it I can't I can't
not sorry where is it curious what this
car we're just running around this train
that hit the city can't leave us alone
it's just right here and we'll drive it
back to her one of the cycles headed
like a laser wheel which I'm really
right there I love her so much
and I'd open the barrier yet and the
cables cut normally like you just go
find the cable and alright we'll give
her the copy she's been waiting too long
exactly priorities Nicholas says have
you come across any bugs or glitches i
can't I can't honestly answer that
question because we had room we had like
a review build of the game and then this
is gnarly access to all the games so
wouldn't be fair I don't know what the
final bill is like but nothing
consistent or major you are my favorite
person this was so necessary hey Alice
boys rise and grinds back in business
and that coffee's on me huh Lucifer I
would not be shown any other
and we're still going over the copy yeah
was boost it now he still wants his copy
just for the record he wants the mug I
mean we could all just go straight and
see no man and like just put your mouse
under the the faucet before the coffee
nope nope minions are being revived by
your clothes I did wait what are you
good he decided it doesn't work I killed
him baby died I don't even know where
that second one came from my buddy
every time we pull out a new weapon we
gotta realize mileage does vary on
weapons I will say I mean it's like very
normal for this game so then you can
just put the shield down wherever oh
yeah Justin I was talking to some people
in the chat at least no manual exercise
I heard this has emos it does it's a
little bit weird because you can't I
haven't found a button to do them on
gamepad plug into pieces why didn't you
try to reload his weapon that had no
ammo all right all right going back to
our other guns you know I just haven't
been super impressed with the guns I've
been picking up lately but that's how
this game works it's just everything is
very random Aaron says such an awesome
mission love the battles over coffee
bradle I plant what seemed oddly
relatable and like personable
I would totally throw hands over some
cocky
oh that's the commander all right that
mug is are you good
I have not been counting but the number
of people have now died over this cup of
coffee is revive you that's my gun okay
worried there for a second
yeah mid tree I'll show you in one sec
after we're done murdering the universe
there's kept copy mid tree there's a
cell provide I'm so getting coffee after
this dream I know I'm actually to the
very last few drops of my coffee okay so
this one here old you that's quick
breather where is it old you here we go
old you so you can revive yourself at
any time during a fight once you get mid
tree and black also has one where his
it's like cute and sad it seems I'm so I
picked up a mod and it's locked right
now it's the one I can't really point to
it here we go to the mouse yeah it's
this one right here so these these don't
unlock until a couple planets in some of
these are intended for endgame or like
New Game+ and like this slot opens up
your gun slot opens later I think this
one's almost at the end of the game and
this one's in a bit but not not as quick
as you would get them in games oh snap
Roberts Lake Rob's like you guys want
coffee I could deliver some we just
I know I'm like something very tempting
I know this seems like a small thing but
even this little taste of the world we
lost it keeps us going you know at least
till tomorrow morning then we'll do it
all again would you do me a favor
hey here's the burger mission malla Wan
recently took over the dynasty diner
which was pumping out food for our
people before it got taken go find the
owner this is like you know
stereotypical movie intern work on
another level hey go get us coffee
all right go grab our lunch but on
another level murder everybody every
single human being in order to achieve
Nicolas asked can you store higher-level
weapons for later absolutely yeah so you
can either do it with sanctuary there's
like a number of ways to do it so like
in the stream what level are we right
now we're 10 I'm probably not gonna get
to 12 and I'd rather just take the cash
so you can either just pay money for a
bigger inventory or you can go up to
sanctuary and stuff it in the vault or
you can put it on the wall in vaults
there's a lot of ways to do it no this
one do you want to see a magic trick
is that a Randi that might be a really
[ __ ] right reference oh snap rob is so
serious about this coffee delivery I
feel like I'm pretty serious about it
zero how do you take your coffee
Aeryn just just with some milk nice hot
salt I mean it depends on the day but I
think it's mostly hot coffee here okay
okay let's get it better making it rain
launches up two three grenades okay now
you're gonna start seeing this Merve
let's make it rain
oh that's level 12 yeah see you like I
can't even really buy anything now
right now everything's way above my
level so okay let's go get some burgers
yeah I think I think we'll be okay I
think I can wait till after his dream to
read up on my coffee since I I had one
cup already I'm not so desperate but Rob
you can go ask Jael where do we find
this poop gun so to make sure we do that
before the stream is over that like
there's there's probably two really two
more really good missions here on this
planet and one of them is this burger
gun and the other one's a fake gun and
again for those in chat don't forget you
periodically go to your social tabs when
you go over to your mail and like as you
complete challenges you'll get mailed
weapons and actually you can mail those
weapons to your friends who are also
playing the game pretty rad I'd be
enjoying myself oh good question
manal what's your ideal burger I think
you should take that question okay I
will start because
I'm actually a pretty simple when it
comes to like burgers I didn't say the
bun and the cheese and and that's it
maybe some mango depending on where I'm
getting the burger from I like mustard
and ketchup but it's not an every place
type of condiment for me just go classic
I like it yeah works how about what
about in the chat now that we're talking
about food dealers and dealers kill
kilovolts now the wannabes dynasty diner
yeah yeah well we're gonna come back
here in a sec yeah those burgers I guess
we gotta locate something else oh yeah
we gotta find faux fur according to this
unfortunately having already played I
kind of know where to go so that's why I
went to that place
oh snap chassis said Shake Shack all day
okay Rob has the intel on where to get
the to fun side quests on Promethea area
called electra city
thank you Ron I think electricity
doesn't open up into okay
okay it's yours if you're super adamant
about bringing me some coffee I'll take
iced coffee it's a little bit of half
and a half and there's um it's like a
it's not sugar but it's the green sugar
replacement packet I put one of those if
you're up for it that's actually why I
don't ask people to give me coffee
because I feel like I don't like laying
out all those tiny details all right
nobody's got their taste
Justin says I like everything on my
burger totally feel that sometimes
around it like I just don't like raw
onions so I'm not a huge fan of places
that really overdo it a lot of people I
know are in love with White Castle but
it's definitely not my cup of tea like a
whole diced onion on one little slider
it drives me crazy understandable that's
a very dramatic
stop go on go in all right
as expected we're gonna take out some
Queens time to commit diner murders
[Applause]
William says do you dip your burger in
ketchup or put the ketchup inside zipper
I've not heard of dipping your burgers
that's interesting
I feel like for fries you know there's
two types people feel like surprise all
over pineapple on burger doesn't sound
as drying is like pineapple on a pizza
which is actually just a popular thing -
I was gonna just do this real quick
humor to get back I kind of want to
start throwing grenades again yeah we
showed off the two ability for a big
which means I have to remember how to
get rid of slot - and slow down here we
go unequip okay
I don't just want my grenades back right
now I think when you're fighting up a
level that can be very useful to have
that shield or when you're playing with
friends just be that whitecastle of you
buy a suitcase full of sliders I have
done this already okay
Nicholas says is it worth keeping the
higher-level weapons early in the game
yeah it is I mean honestly it guns and
vorlons are very random and when you
find one with rare like honestly what
you should probably do anytime you find
a gun that you think is gonna be
interesting you actually shoot it ahead
of time yeah it's a tough call because a
lot of guns have weird properties like
every once in a while you'll pick up
again that just says something you've
never seen before so yeah it's probably
worth warding some of them and coming
back and trying him later but chances
are you're gonna throw out a lot of them
and you know guns are only good for so
long before they become obsolete so I
wouldn't stress about it if you're
somebody who really stresses about loot
I think I did I did more so my first
run-through and I'm kind of less worried
about it just around there
Thomas says you all need to get the gun
names smiles on pizza is like the worst
thing in the world but for me personally
I just don't like sweetness dessert but
I wish it's a personal truck I would
consider pineapple a personal worse if
you like if you like pineapple like more
power to you if you don't like pineapple
it kind of infects everything it touches
like the pineapple taste spreads oh snap
the coffee delivery has arrived and we
didn't have to kill a single person
thank you best job ever
burgers my dude all right special I'm
getting a burger for lunch
oh wait cheers Aaron let's cheers our
classes were like yeah oh yeah oh yeah
it's beautiful
what we gotta kill you know it's really
weird this run I haven't found any Atlas
guns at my level they're really good
they have a tracker on them so burgers
are life
Oh
ready don't love it too much here you go
strutting up the shoutout IRL but there
it isn't a shout out some apparently uh
nothin game Reagan's William said rouses
an IRL loot box for the copy
look at a bad for killing rats you know
living their best rat lives now we need
burgers bro this sacrifice was necessary
although yeah oh so they eat each other
by the way that this is me and how
that's how the rat life works whenever
you kill a rat they start eating eating
the carcasses and evolving sound effect
[Music]
how long will this stream be going for
well we're allowed to play up until a
specific mission but we're gonna try to
knock out all the side missions and
stuff in until we get to that point so I
don't know what do you think I'm gonna
wear a side twist we have it's over we
can still go for the poop fun yeah
that's definitely still on the agenda
I'd say it obviously there's a lot of
time coming Trevor we'll probably we
probably won't get to that point in the
game to be honest it's pretty pardon
like at least a couple of hours so we'll
be up for at least a little while longer
gotta get the big in
these pistols are really good crowd
control you know to that earlier
question absolutely everything hey get
away rats some point they would learn
hey Remy
yeah everything on this planet has been
dropping around 12 and I just hit 11 so
I honestly haven't been able to clip
again I picked up in a while well we did
kind of rush down the very beginning
part yep which the side missions are
really fun in this game and honestly it
is there's no reason outside of you know
the way that we do review is trying to
get their games to not take your time
play them side missions well some burger
is y'all skills time for skills says I
just want to say I really appreciate you
guys streaming this game while I'm at
work
hey no problem man we're happy to help
take our burger was he the number one
commander that she was pissed about he
might have been the number one commander
that she was angry that wasn't her
because she's the number one commander
thought that was the coffee commander
got war never got the burger now get the
burger commander
let's go burger bot where are we doing
this
billion asks do you think this is gonna
be the best Borderlands because I know
some of my friends who haven't played
Borderlands is gonna get it's definitely
the best version of Borderlands as you
know as good sequels kind of it's the
most Indian version of Borderlands so
yeah like if you're gonna start
somewhere
although I will say I mean I don't know
I wouldn't ask you to start boil and
stew with your friends right now because
I thank you a very long time but they're
not gonna have the emotional connection
like the story the story does have like
you mentioned all the time
[Music]
related to other characters you're gonna
have a much deeper emotional connection
to the story than they will but they'll
have a lot of fun definitely been fun
whistles pretty early on in the game we
hardly even used like the scene I ran
into the same
we definitely are punching above our way
right now and actually I honestly maybe
I should switch back to the shield um
Fox is asking about the preload for the
game for Friday yeah you can preload it
I think if you pre-ordered it or
something you get an extra day the copy
the copy that they just gave us says
early access so I'm assuming there's
that's probably a free vote involved all
right well actually made the launcher
work Wow I just did not hang for any
length of time
oh wow
burger bot is just in the back freaking
out house burger bot to you range on
this is pretty good yeah do that
learn learned an apex crowd Street works
burger but help us out man throw some
burgers at it we know you got a gun for
that okay yep
still just solve all level 12 although I
gonna say you should probably just start
tossing anything I'm not using and don't
like you don't like you you're good
because of economy shotguns have just
been absolutely saving us and you're
kind of trash nice boxes shout out from
Norway thanks for tuning in
from Norway I love that got people all
around the grill oh you know what
jean-luc might have picked up the
mission give me one second I think
there's saw a mission pickup back here I
want to make sure you don't miss the
poop gun pickup yeah um
actually let me scroll back up because
Jordan said you go for right now I think
pretty sure you find the side quest
while doing the kill kilovolt mission
okay kill kilovolt is also a pretty
heavy boss fight what's up Justin he
says hashtag Billy fgc but I but I let
it
[Music]
random excessive sliding so the robots
are spawned really well to UM toxic
damage I'm saying the name wrong but
that's what it is
[Music]
kogai already
you automatically pick up loot in this
game you do not
I really just need an atlas these guys
are so much easier when you have Atlas
weapons Wow
what no oh
stop burning stop burning oh ho oh it's
a Big Daddy you know I think I made a
mistake getting rid of my grenades I'm
gonna give it to whoever suggested we go
with two skill trees my grenades are
just not doing it right now let's go
back loadout no you know props to props
to : that out we're fighting up a level
so right now this seems to be more
useful
show us gun customization we kind of
talked about a little bit earlier so you
can't customize them you can just sort
of see what that random attribute oh
yeah
shoot the ball oh yeah god I got thrown
a far they all have the throwing
accuracy like professional pitcher
I just want to take down and Big Daddy
however I do have a tackle again
the poison there's something it's hurtin
Jane Jane doesn't handle pain very well
I'm not gonna lie
yeah he's a bit of a baby
okay this is pretty good area attacks
out of ammo my life in this game
we may have to consider our loadout if I
can get his minions down we can just see
the the big daddy sandwich move yeah
we'll do that
all right oh I think that's what they
meant by customisation not parts but the
skins oh yeah boy I've only seen oh yeah
now I can definitely that oh he's almost
dead one hit thanks Jordan
for your clarifications all right free
got
Roach said he called him a baby Bay he
was literally on fire big baby
maybe okay all the reload yeah okay
serpentine all right Jess get something
for me that's level ten oh yeah nice
unicorns
hey use the corner cheese yeah they're
all right handed so we already all the
left-handed guns went out into space
earlier okay
all right we are not as bad as you wear
a second ago yeah we got held back
fifteen bullets how the others legendary
weapons if you get on your first
playthrough what I don't remember what
color that is
so there's purple ones I get a look up
what color that actually hit you know
honestly the number over a gun really
means very little I'm sorry the color of
a gun means very little it's more about
you know it gives you a chance of
rolling a better gun but more often than
not you pick something up and it's a
it's just it looks one way on paper and
it just behaves another way once you
start shooting it okay this is gonna
melt him a little bit better either said
the shield and clone just rocks but I
heard spindle does more damage not sure
those it flown have so much utility this
game has so many options heck yeah
that's kind of something we're talking
about earlier to because we have like
the two ability up but didn't have the
grenades but then the clone also has so
many different aspects no suddenly lots
of work with in the sense that we were
talking about what the best solo forum
idea
there's some self revive options with
this with the cartoon I think when we
did our first lasers we kind of felt
black with the best solar built because
of his familiars his good boys and he
also gets a self provide mystery but
Dane also get self revive me trees I
think it comes down to whether you want
a digital good boy or a very good boy
good boy it's really what it comes down
to all right we're gonna we're gonna
live dangerously here
oh yeah he was definitely charging that
one up
oh yeah he staggers on that hit what
ammo do I have left always out of ammo
you have I got this like two guns
oh yeah he resists fire
I already am I really out of a shot game
on now I have one gun love I am bingo on
everything except for a sniper rifle and
I don't have a sniper rifle well this is
interesting
we're completely out of man can I do
this nope he's recharging if you leave
this area come back with all this can I
fry em to death man you are worthless
burger but with your wavy arms yeah you
have more ammo there's more ammo laying
around all right sure all the burgers
and have them explode like Squidward is
and then a volt crab heads to the person
who suggested earlier we probably should
go back at the sanctuary again Andrea
pon-3 up on our ammo abilities or sir
ammo capacities searching for ammo what
are you your level 12 you don't help me
yeah again this is why you really need
to hold on to all types a mo
nope checking only how are you damaged
wives a lot more damage sure does more
damage and I we got this coming back
with a vengeance and 26 rounds yeah this
is gonna happen we got 24 rounds 26
rounds 54 rounds we got this this is
gonna happen even though all his health
probably came back his shields probably
did but we got shields you got shields
we got shields
destroyed yeah will ring-around-the-rosy
action
slow race to the finish unless they run
out of ammo which is possible
sporting the environment hey - yeah
fiery says I sure hope this game has
good replay value I would be stuck with
some of the things I can't I'm knocking
please finish the first place right
there's a pose like a New Game+ and
there's a lot of things that open up at
the end
it depends what you're after really and
it depends why you want to replay it if
you're you know like I think I think
we're in this weird place right now
where everybody expects game to last
forever those are just being a like a
very solid experience I kind of feel
like I know it's hard to think if
there's just so much out right now like
a lot of us are gonna do the Call of
Duty beta oh my god I'm out of ammo
okay go right ahead he had a blue snipe
somewhere it wasn't classified this is
it's this this one it's weird it's
actually classified as a rifle Oh
interesting but I thought the same thing
I think we'll have an opportunity okay
just just be dead be dead guy
this one some burgers our chariot of
music
second is cheap it's cheap it has no
ammo yeah but that's been like every gun
please give me an atlas at my level
you're almost feasible as though so you
could maybe pick one of these up and
hold on to them yeah let's drop a 10 I
already have a couple 12 she's not a big
fan of launchers so we'll drop you
you're 12
well you fire many bosses for
Legendary's during the stream probably
not today we're kind of checking out
side missions here and playing within
the boundaries that were allowed to
stream today we're gonna go we're gonna
return to Lorelai if you want to do that
upstairs instead of downstairs
I got 46 hot bullets the other thing is
so you'll see these chests scattered
throughout the world that's something
you can unlock later so don't worry
about this oh you need something
specific to break the crystals off oh
yeah
you know I regret dropping a sniper
rifle even though it wasn't at my level
you kind of need all of your guns be
sued just run out all the time
Master burly said he's so ready to play
this game I really like it a lot and
this Friday I played through I was a
huge fan of tube this feels like just a
super dial then improvement on to
someone's chasing but it's fine
how many people got to die for these
burgers oh wow
Aaron please yes we got this area where
so many people have now died for these
burgers sorry says the guns seem a
million times cooler much more punchy
but the villain seemed nowhere close to
handsome Jack yeah we've got always the
problem like when you make the best
villain of all time
always nice to see a friendly face
you're mentioning how he gets all fired
when your burger grubbing prick has been
a right thorn in my ass but now he's
dead well done indeed I'll as well first
coffee now burgers the cornerstones of
civilization
piece by piece we're really starting to
put this city back together burger again
please tell me it's actually at my level
no almost there yeah we're close okay
well this is the burger gun it fires
burgers
I love the skin it's covered in burgers
I'm hungry now it's delicious
they do like delicious nice thick patty
got the cheese that's true yeah to the
earlier to the earlier comments this is
the full burger he's not this is not the
minimal burger but all the fixin's all
right so we're gonna definitely star
that so we don't get rid of it a voice
of curiosity is says do I have to play
Borderlands 1 and 2 and
to play this um you will so the short
answer is no maybe go on youtube and
watch the cutscenes from the earlier
game just to get a feel of the storyline
you'll you will miss some of the
emotional story beats if you haven't
played the other games
but you'll get it I mean the the
villains as pointed out are not
particularly complicated they're
basically YouTube streamers it's a good
plug I actually really do like the idea
of it right deston just point that
burger gun my way
I kind of like that games as of late
I've really been embracing like stream
culture and stuff right like in Tekken 7
Juliet her big female is that she's a
screamer too it makes it makes so much
sense in this universe I mean the idea
is that all these bandits have just been
neglected and forgotten which they
happen and murdered and and cast aside
and so there was a there's a space for
the clips of twins to come in and
basically give them hope through social
media which is actually very
contemporary it's exactly you know kind
of what's happening now though I think
the plot is like the plot is right on
for modern for being a modern story you
know whether whether they're evil enough
for you or not Bob Jones how's it going
he says it's nice to see Aaron on the
stream it is our first time shooting
together actually yeah
always happy to come on in and show
something off our plan and we've been
streaming for like three hours right now
there's a lot there's a lot in this game
and get me to that earlier question do
you need to replay it that's why I don't
think you need to replay it if you don't
want to because there is just a lot I
don't know how many hours Gordon's talk
now but you definitely have not explored
this all the side missions
and honestly this is my second
playthrough not not from the full end of
the game but you know someone in the
chat mentioned using the both skill
trees in my first playthrough I didn't
do that I because I really want a
grenade so I'm having a good time now
following up with the dual skill trees
on Zayn's yeah maybe after we body I'll
be ruined and we could check out some of
those skins there's no no reason the way
actually I mean so like honestly I don't
know where our skins came from we they
were there I think when we fired up our
game oh but you can't change weapon
skins here so like obviously oh sorry
unfortunately it's the only one that
I've earned so far actually I honestly
don't know where the skins come from I
don't know if it's a purchase thing or
yeah but Jordan says I'm like 40 hours
in and nowhere near done so these are
these are like your chibis you can earn
on your gun so this one came from moxie
I got some socks you got a little cute
cute dude keeps comparing ya frakkin
toaster so yeah they're pretty small on
the gun like if you can see it's right I
can't
he's a mouse but it's actually it's
almost it's almost hidden by my second
skill tree right it's found in the
bottom right hanging on the side again
it's probably in like slightly different
places for different guns Oh Sam's back
santoku says I'm glad there's a lot of
things to do yeah I mean they spent a
long time bringing this back so stop
shooting me second so jeebies like the
TV it's just a little thing right there
hanging off the charge handle shooting
me trying to show no one else gonna die
with the burger I'm convinced some of
these guns shoot their armor without
admitting it on paper yeah some of these
guns seem to chew their armor way faster
than other guns
so yeah this is if you because if you
want to post up and this is against the
shield kit for posting yeah that was a
nice surprise
I actually didn't I didn't realize that
the first time I played which is one of
the reasons I avoided it okay okay so
dreadin said weapon skins can either be
rare drops or a gain from certain
sidequest he seems to come by them with
iridium too but can't remember for sure
oh yeah we can go check out URLs URLs -
know it I think they weren't URLs -
after this we can just pop back up a
sanctuary really fricking it ourselves a
lot of things for iridium and you pick
up a significantly increased rate of
iridium later in the game so it's not so
common early later on it becomes pretty
easy to come by
so this pistol is probably not supposed
to be good against armor because the
fire type but seems to be so I swear I
think I'm convinced they're definitely
other stats under the surface that just
don't show up
which is why in this game it's always
good to just test every gun new vines
try it all out you know like try any gun
one never get launched this guy juggling
is satisfying man he was walk through
the bones the spine oh whoa we're sorry
was I even killing in the right place I
was wasn't I yes no no okay yes you can
buy them from girl there's lots of
spinach cheese but the question is can
maybe use on everything it seems like
today yeah every gun that pulled up has
had that same orange skin option you
know it's interesting I have noticed
that your
your mission sometimes randomly cycle or
I don't know if I'm just hitting it
during combat what is the quickest way
to earn still points it's really
straightforward just do every side
missions Daniel please hi man I honestly
like the reason I didn't use the
shield's in the first playthrough is I
didn't realize you could just pick it up
and now that I you can do that it's
super helpful
oh I hope that thing's not bad we all
know zane doesn't like being on fire you
forgot
his invisible wall in front of me
there's little things nothing nothing
like too bad in this game sometimes the
geometry likes a hitbox for the geometry
isn't exactly what you think it is
can you change the crosshair ooh good
question I thought I saw something in
the menu like we could always take a
look
something anyway and race going on being
on fire not unless it's NBA Jam Jane is
right he's got a particularly baby about
it to throw the shield honesty is that
was interesting and it didn't do it
needed like finish okay I guess the
shield this is a bit of damage that's
funny I'm gonna have to test that I know
her so close oh you have got to try the
arcturion super black it is honestly the
most wonderful thing in the whole world
sugars please sorry it's already cut you
off there for a second let me just get
some skins yeah and I think this was the
mission we can find the reason all right
moist the flag that is a name operative
skin okay yeah my face hole that's the
man's a little bit awkward when he's
into it and already known so we can toss
scoob's roasty day you guys alright well
we finally find a sniper rifle that we
can actually use bit late but uh okay
we're good I don't know if one of those
skins was a weapon skin but we can
oops probably was not but let's try nope
but you know we're gonna apply this skin
now we have an orange rifle all right
party owns goodbye
guns I don't feel as bad this play
they're leaving guns behind
actually don't know if I want a rocket
launcher because there's no ammo for
those things
yeah rocket launchers and snipers I
think both feel like they need about
another balanced path oh here's his
buddy
zero ironically does a lot of I want to
be their friends I was gonna kill
everybody be my friend meant to say the
bro
we're so close to 12 burger
time to do yeah they'd like this a
little bit of damage all right get in
there did you clone touch Ely that's
just me it's like get in there myself go
me go home go other me no obeah
your corner
huh seconds at range Williams like Aaron
shoot first make friends later if
there's anyone loves somebody be our
friend
I mean you murdered every murder is kind
of an impediment to your friendship but
you know okay action pose that's a very
small fork by the way oh crap
[Music]
yes this game does drop on Friday lucky
enough to be able to show it up let's
add anyway this mellow indica
kind of hard to sleep when you're
getting knocked out of position I have
to daddy daddy you know what we're
stronger than we were back then they're
getting it from multiple sides what's
lost in there
now let's take the the back bowl
what works big damage
get out of here guy
yeah I'm at the end of a good man I am
finding the shields so much more useful
this run frozen zero frozen
wellthey run it what ammo here
there we go all right house leveling up
slow or quick if you do the side
missions it's at a pretty good clip we
haven't so I think we see no breach
though it's mostly is the way we've been
playing yeah we've been chugging along
to level 12 here
we're almost there though then we can
use the burden Lulu that headshot
critical his dome is on fire then I
found the pistols to be particularly
good in this game
hey another Big Daddy
hold
Wow where you go others come back here
Oh kind of quick skill let me try to
saddle up I should probably know better
than to try that these ubers isn't the
fire damage so we're gonna use something
else Louie says have you found any
Jacobs pistol yeah I'm just not a fake
use of the reload time but if you like
digging pistols they create like a
maniac William says I'll probably play a
Mara since she because I like fighting
games is she like a melee heavy man oh
wow what do you I don't know what you
are I'm gonna pick you up cuz you're
cool yeah and we're very close to being
able to use it yeah what's no use to me
anymore I've kind of moved on from you
you've been you've been good thing asked
about the ps4 version but we've actually
only had the chance to play the PC
version so far so I wanna save any
thoughts on that - laughter - try it out
oh Christ
you couldn't kill them with the shield I
get them low enough too far let's try it
now
I think you did like what did it do like
ten damage it's gonna be hard to get it
down for the try all right what's our
next thing
what's the craziest gun you've found so
far uh so there's a bigger gun there's a
boot gun there's a gun that with a giant
face that spits alien lasers which I
thought was really cool I like the
creativity yeah you know it being a
Borderlands game every couple levels you
just find a new favorite gun but I love
the alien barrels and again with an
alien barrel just looks ridiculous where
do you want me to go electricity loss
weapons depot I think this is it okay
yeah here we go
let me level we definitely got here too
fast like I'm 11
what are you unlocked weapon skin oh we
found a weapon skin all right I kind of
wish this is a general Borderlands thing
over a bunch of different years but I
kind of wish skins didn't take a slot Oh
interesting like it doesn't really make
sense for me to have to throw a weapon
down and pick this up go back to my
inventory unlock it take the gun back up
it's a like just kind of excessive
process okay make sure I got my best
shield right now I'm gonna toss this cuz
need some inventory space
you are like a flat off something around
there and like these you you got to
store those because you can't use them
until later okay
is there a character that uses spells
yes FLAC has a stealth tree you can
definitely go invisible cool and regen
health sounds useful I don't know if
he's a roguish I don't think it actually
somebody wanted to use a Jacob's pistol
let me see if there's something I don't
care about right now cuz somebody kind
of wanted to see Jacobs we haven't used
this cough gun in a while and not
whatever pistols getting these
I got another game anyway so here we'll
do a Jacob's pistol I'm not a big fan oh
dang that chibis cool though yeah they
do crits really well so yeah black tub
with a four does have it they do it they
do have a South tree okay yeah but I'm
just not good with sniper rifles yeah
let's see if you're better than the one
I have but otherwise you gotta know what
kind of player you are I'm not a sniper
player you are I always watched like
really good players use sniper and then
I pick it up Oh expectation and reality
are so far from each other area you know
what I like that one that was a
semi-auto goodbye a sniper rifle
Aiden asks does it run well on PC what's
your setup and FPS we haven't clocked it
so I'm not a hundred percent sure but I
haven't noticed any like bad frame rate
drops except for there was just one
there was one thing happening during the
stream when we were like going to a new
area we kind of bugged out a little bit
but that was really the only major time
yeah but it's pretty good because we've
been in a few like action battles now
that have had a bunch of people nearby a
bunch of goons and stuff now that being
said most of us in the office played
solo so I don't know I can't vouch for
what happens when you have a lot of
people playing
it's way less kid take zero zone
what's the lunchroom tradesies oh yeah
so I probably should drop another gun
just in case I don't want him to give me
again and like not be able to use it 114
versus 26 okay good bye you are the
weakest link and you know if anybody
join us late I've been running out of
ammo constantly so hey you'll see me
pick up and open every closet
[Music]
you know I'm just gonna I'm not gonna
say it back I'm singing it up all in
that
how many loading screens are there not
that many
no just transitions between zones I
think I really only see one where like
[Music]
walls cannot roll - of course I know it
wasn't no old sailors how can I snap
every doesn't look give plenty of
corporate AOS immediate great source of
blackmail
someone asked if there were dealing
grenades there are yeah like the last
game a lot of the you can you can find
grenades that return house yep
zero is cool I mean I feel like it's
almost mandatory to have some sort of
like robot person where are you
back at the coffeehouse walls cannot
hold us Oh
let's go zero alright he's pretty
stylish bake that wall away zero
probably just has no doors in his own
house they're all slashed through yeah
it only works once and then you realize
that doesn't doesn't work after that
here we go giggle mind paints oh that's
what we were gonna do oh yeah it's like
too many things focus on right now we
got a skin you oh nice I like it
okay that's kind of cool it looks like a
pan can't exploded on it but I'm down I
don't know I kind of wish those apply
all but right you deserve the treatment
and you deserve the treatments all right
now we got dope skins yeah yeah I make
no promises I might switch away from
this pistol quickly
giggle mind
definitely not an AI that Breen is super
real the eyeballs are still attached
Williamson I feel like zeros homeless
and just lives off the land
yeah that's probably true which is why
he has no respect for Doris he just it's
not it is not a tribute the man just has
no use for Doris you've been exploded
sue me I gotta get behind him which is
actually red clones are good for
yeah the clone seems like perfect
workaround for getting 4d I'm like
trying to bob and weave myself over here
that is just a habit I have when I'm
playing or watching games learn from
years of experience yeah what's that
rocket launchers why not alright wait
for abilities come back
he's got shield I got a shield we all
got shields
oh that hurt
out of him our three favorite word's of
the day great minds I don't know about
the intelligence fire all right I mean
this because he has a big brain of using
a hundred percent of it you know that is
an excellent point he appears to be
using a small part of that big range
it's just for show too much brain for
one Giga - yeah does the pause menu also
pause battle on higher difficulty in
solo play it definitely does oh and
higher difficulties Wow have to get
questions I've only tried it on normal
so far I don't know that's a good
question
all right what we got ammo wise we got
SMG ammo we got pistol ammo SMG I think
after this boss battle will definitely
hit level 12 better to do it and then
it's burger guns all the way
will they make DLC characters I mean I
know they did mention VLC and breathe
hum alright giggle mind off
[Music]
please die Giga mine I'm asking politely
what does guy
this soda will for you to be a dead
[Music]
I think he also drops I don't know if
it's random actually but for me he
dropped an alien on this okay burger
again I need to like I seriously did
inventory okay if we finally hit level
12 so we're gonna grab burger again
then we're gonna I'm just gonna shred
anything that's low level so gun with
legs is there a gun with legs
most of the TDR weapons when you reload
do things with legs okay trash there's a
burger gun require ammo though or does
it just materialize burgers out of thin
air it unfortunately does require ammo
although that would be cool if that kind
of technology existed or you could just
materialize a burger out of thin air you
will be a wealthy individual of you
ending really world hunger
if you invent that just gonna shred a
bunch of things real quick bear with me
it'll be like Cloudy with a Chance of
Meatballs
she will stuff these in the vaults okay
my father once said I was 12th in line
to run the company so I made eleven
quick little cuts to the family
[Music]
saying is not a nice dude oh snap
looks like looks like we're getting
booted Aaron Rob said our desks are on
fire no no and we must return I can at
least shoot some people just burger gun
we didn't get to get the poop gun but we
can at least use this burger gun we got
four burgers holy for what a tease
that's what you get you get four burgers
we finally got the level and everything
we needed for this gun and we got four
bullets for burger bullets oh yeah yeah
you were talking about the alien guns
did we actually get you know someone
asked earlier about grinding bosses so I
think I got it as a random drop because
some my co-workers didn't get it
orangy is on your side for this run that
you don't care about isn't that always
the game that works then you know that
that answers that question so we asked
you earlier back riding certain bosses
he'll kilowatt all right here goes
I know the burgers will kill these guys
because they're robots but oh yeah they
definitely ate a burger they did you
know all that cholesterol those burgers
just clogged their Robo arteries
instantly and now they're no more and I
bet your meaty definitely meaty because
it was like rats meat so let me before
if we have to we have to get going then
let me head back up to sanctuary just to
show people the vault who haven't you
see I love that just make some flyaways
here
Oh SEC Ron said the burger gun has a
little spongebob inside making turkey
burgers I'd be so down with that he's
got a too cute to kill have a burger the
last burger the last burger he'll ever
have okay let me fast travel up to
sanctuary yeah and then we'll show
people we had some questions about skins
so let me answer that real quick and I
can show you the Volt I want to see some
of the other skins really appreciate
people joining us I know we put on a
marathon this morning you guys all right
so I'll answer some questions pretty
quickly so this is your gun wall for
somebody who anybody didn't join us
earlier you can stick your favorite gun
up here come back and get it later
admire it remember it marry conduit if
you feel like you had good times
together
does it bring you joy these are weapons
that you can stuff in your vault these
are from my other characters so the
answer is yes you can stuff it in and
come back and get it later it's cool
which was something that somebody wanted
next up we're gonna check skins emotes
so haven't found any emotes to buy skins
these are like the character skins and
these are you just earned by playing
ectoplasm how good do I look and the
last question we had was can you buy
gunskins big said did the burger does
the burger gonna collect ants if you'll
even look around it really should so
this is your epic gun shop this is where
you spend that iridium supply so for
example these guns what they do
differently is they'll interact with
your abilities so this one will do
things like regenerate well I have my
digi clone up and they also just look
really damn cool so they're all that and
okay
it's here there are weapon skins cool
gun Fetty looks cute already so these
you just buy with iridium map oh wow
okay I'm gonna apply this on my other
character
I don't know buy it now oh you know what
actually I think it is across all your
characters it's 300 I think we can
afford that one anyway yeah these are
all things that looks like nothing
black dragon yep I'm gonna bye-bye
unicorns and rainbows heck yeah when I
get back to my desk okay cool are there
any other questions we can answer about
customization of characters or something
on sanctuary because otherwise we will
yeah that is gonna wrap it up for the
stream thank you guys so much for
hanging out with us for like I don't
know almost 4 hours now there's
definitely some good times lots of fun
it's just so much to do also like we
definitely could have just kicked kept
on playing of knowing dragged us out of
here so thank you guys so much for
tuning in and be sure to tune in every
single day GameSpot live we stream daily
weekdays at 11 a.m. Pacific time we
obviously tuned in a little early today
because of the Borderlands hype so thank
you guys so much for sticking with us we
really appreciate it
hope you enjoyed the stream as well and
hope you enjoy it playing some
Borderlands this Friday we'll see you
guys later
have a copy
[Music]